you
Hey, Christoph, how's it going?
Yeah, it's pretty good, you know, uh, I feel like this, yeah, it's always kind of true,
but yeah, work has been pretty, pretty crazy.
Been trying to get caught up on stuff and including the reading, so yeah,
but I'll see if we can stick to our every Thursday schedule from now on, but yeah,
we'll just have to see, I guess.
Sounds great.
Yeah, I didn't have much time for the reading as a consciousness conference all week, so
that was very tiring.
Oh, interesting, consciousness conference, that sounds cool though.
So what was like any new breakthroughs or anything discussed there?
Um, well, a lot of really interesting food for thought, but you know, we talked about
before you and I about the free energy principle active inference and this
situation that we're in, that if you can draw a mark of blanket, then you may be able to use the
machinery of active inference to start making some inferences about the system's behavior,
but the question is how to discover the mark of blankets, and it seems that people working on this
consciousness theory called IIT, integrated information theory, that's the kind of thing
that might give us tools to discover, you know, subsystems that could be considered these like
blanketed modules by basically looking at how they integrate information.
And it's somehow related to the entropy production within the system, but the mathematics of that
was a little bit, you know, above my pay grade, especially in a 10-minute talk or a 15-minute
talk, but there are some really interesting relationships, so it might be possible to
analyze the system from that perspective, you just look how the information flows,
and it will give you some way of basically automatically discovering what are the,
you know, important subsystems of a greater system, so a lot of interesting things like that.
Okay, I see, so basically given some kind of graphical model, there's some people who are
working out methods to find the markup or the subsets of that model with this kind of conditional
independence condition of the markup blanket, I guess.
Yes, yes, so IIT has a slightly different take on it, but basically as you have some kind of
graphical model, we have a transition matrix, and you can do some analysis on, you know, run
a simulation of the system, and you can say like, well, they have a measure called phi,
and this is the measure of the integrated information, so the important thing is how the
information from the parts of the system is integrated in some of its subcomponents,
and, you know, the idea there is that essentially systems that have a certain kind of degree of
integrated information are more conscious than systems that do not. These information is just,
you know, randomly flowing through the system. I think there are some arguments to be made that
this is necessarily an incomplete view from, you know, computational perspective, like if you have
computational irreducibility, then from your perspective, measuring this, you know, computing
these reducible mathematical models may not capture the full dynamics of the system. It might
simply look to you as if it was not integrating the information, it integrates anyway.
But, as far as tools goes, it's pretty good.
Yeah, I never totally got the idea of integrated information. Yeah, what is
integrated information really as like an information theoretic quantity kind of?
I can't really explain it myself. I just simply know that it's some kind of measure,
so there's some, you know, you get the transition matrix of the system and you run the simulation
and then you can compute it in some way. What it does precisely, I never looked into it because
that's not my main interest. But that was one of the interesting things.
There was a guy who developed a really interesting presentation where he looked at
canonical neural networks. So that's a, you know, stochastic dynamical system from the
perspective of integrated information theory and from the perspective of active inference.
And he showed a lot of correspondences there. So that's really cool. But yeah,
one thing that really struck me is that there is this, I think this duality is super important to
always consider and it shows up even when I'm reading the solid state physics book and all
the models and so on is that you have a system with unknown number of degrees of freedom and
ultimately it's a quantum system, right? Because all systems are quantum. I don't believe in the
transitions into classical. I think it's a perceptual issue, not a real issue, but decoherence
somehow magically takes quantum away. So we have that. And in order to be able to construct any
kind of model of that, you have to go to a weaker modeling paradigm that's full computational.
You just have to simply forget some aspects of the system. There are infinitely many ways to
slice that system in a way that might make sense. So we do it the way we do it because of
evolutionary objectives, right? We need to keep stable temperature of our bodies so we care about
temperature and things like that. So keeping this duality in mind, I think it's super important
whenever discussing anything. The computational model will give you precise calculation,
but you can't run it too far because of the computational cost. And any kind of
reducible model will allow you to compute farther, deeper into the computation tree,
but you will necessarily lose detail. And that trade-off seems to be,
it's fundamental. I don't know. We will ever find a way to, it can have it too.
So that was kind of cool. A lot of insights like that from various stocks.
Right.
These are the insights I had, not necessarily the speakers.
Yeah, no, no. I definitely agree with, yeah, your kind of point about making kind of counter
intuitively, making the model simpler, oversimplifying allows you to somehow get farther and understanding
how something actually works. Although I was kind of curious about, so you said something about how
you don't think like that, or basically how everything is quantum, right? Like all just
everything eventually boils down to quantum mechanics. But like, you're kind of skeptical
of the idea that we can actually just ignore quantum, or that like quantum mechanics actually
doesn't apply on the macroscopic level, and that like people kind of wave it away with
decoherence, but maybe, you know, everything is actually quantum after all, like even up to the
macroscopic level. But I was kind of curious, like, yeah, could you expand on that a little bit,
or what do you mean by that? Okay, let me give you an example from fluid mechanics, which I think
I'm remembering correctly, but I lost the source, so I can't verify it. I remember reading a story
about the US Navy building some super-duper fast ship, right? And they got the drawing boards,
they designed it, they built it, and it turned out to be really slow. Well, they didn't account for,
you know, because the equations of Navier-Stokes equations that didn't let them see is the
phenomenon, which I believe is called hypercavitation, that when the propellers were spinning so fast,
that it created little pockets of vacuum that was actually pushing against the boat, slowing it down.
So they had to introduce some kind of weird rhythm into how the propellers were spinning to just
create more chaos in the molecules of water so that these pockets of vacuum wouldn't form,
something like that. So I think that's generally fundamentally how
bounded computational observers have to make certain assumptions about the system
that are pertinent to them in order to be able to model the things that they really care about.
And my feeling is that, you know, some kind of magical phase transition from
quantum nature to classical nature is simply something like that. At some level of scale,
you just simply don't care about the effects of the phenomenon. But there's an interesting thing
that Wolfram says, this is not exactly quantum, but it's more dark matter. He says that basically,
he believes that dark matter will turn out to be the caloric of our time, as in we think about it
as matter, because we are familiar with standard model of, you know, particles and interactions,
which is really a model of just interactions, in my opinion, not particles, doesn't say anything
about particles. But it will turn out to be the feature of the structure of space.
Right? So I think this transition from quantum to classical will turn out to be something like
that. And I think it's an observer, I believe that, you know, from thinking about active inference
quite a lot, that it's going to turn out to be an observer, observer specific phenomenon.
Because if you take the world where everything evolves deterministically, and you can simply
take this assumption that you cannot model the entire universe, and you have to make these
probabilistic models, then you basically recover this quantum indeterminism, because you can't
say exactly what the system is going to do. So we can only have like a probabilistic
probability distribution over, you know, its attractor states effectively, that you are going
to observe, it's going to hit you, you know, you're going to observe this and this and this,
because there are more degrees of freedom in the system than what you can observe. So the
coherence is a sort of like that there's something special happening. It simply strikes me as
unnecessary, you can just explain it from this perspective. And if it's unnecessary, then it's
probably not there. Okay, yeah, interesting. Yeah, a lot to think about there for sure. I guess,
well, I don't know, yeah, I guess the way I think about it is that,
well, so just as in any system where you have kind of like emergent structures that like live,
like kind of a higher level of abstraction of what's beneath them, right? Like, if you look at
like what's going on on the lower level in our computers, the bunch of ones and zeroes flowing
around through logic gates. But when we're actually using our computers, we think in terms of much
higher level concepts like, you know, files and programs and things. And I think about it as like
classical physics is the abstraction as the abstract objects that live on top of kind of
the quantum, you know, hardware basically that's running at the base of things.
And when we get up to the macroscopic level, those abstractions, you know, they work really well,
just like when you're using your computer, the idea of a file works really well. You know,
of course, something can go wrong, where you have in physics, we would call them quantum effects,
quantum macroscopic quantum effects. I mean, or from the experimentalist, maybe they would see
that as something going right. But to use my analogy, that would be something kind of going
wrong, where actually the in the computer, if the abstraction of the higher level file system
breaks down, and now we're looking at the properties of the actual hardware, because
something is broken. Similarly, classical physics can, you know, can break down, we can have these
macroscopic quantum effects, I guess. But I mean, that doesn't know if I'd say like that the classical
reality isn't real, because you know, it seems to be the reality we deal with mostly. But I don't
know, maybe it's a slight difference of perspective, I guess. But I'm not saying anything fundamentally
different. Well, you're essentially saying that, you know, I wrap the lower layer into a mark of
blanket and say like, well, I'm statistically independent of the features of the hardware,
given this interface. And what I'm trying to say is that I think it was, I think it was
Andrey Karpati, who said this on Lex Friedman, that we should be trying to look for exploits,
you know, in physics. And if you so if you believe in decoherence, that it's because
the impression I got from people who talk about the decoherence program, they seem to believe
that there is a transition into a different regime. Right. Yeah. But but in computer science, we've
learned a long time ago that all abstractions are leaky. They're only useful until, you know,
suddenly, your latency of a read is high because you went went outside of the cache or whatever.
So you're always by thinking this way, that you're never really in a different regime, you're just
simply looking for an interface. But you're always ultimately interacting with a quantum system.
This may open up possibility of people thinking about ways to, you know, jiggle the system in
such a way that you will see these microscopic quantum effects. If you think that you're in a
transition to a different regime, and everything is classical of this, this way up that it's not
an artifact of somewhat arbitrary partitioning for the interface,
then you may never really think that's possible. So that's the subtle shift.
Interesting. Yeah, I know. I remember seeing that that tweak to about the exploits, which was
which was kind of interesting to me. I mean, I don't know, like, to me, like, it seemed like a
weird way to phrase it, because it's hard, you know, for me to imagine something like an exploit,
you know, per se in physics and that, you know, like, that would almost seem to suggest it could
get you to do like almost whatever you want or something. Or I don't know, I mean, you know,
you could like, well, it's hard to say exactly what's meant by an exploit. But I kind of tend
to think of it more as in like tradeoffs of like, you know, you're even when we exploit new laws of
physics to build new things, we're always going to end up trading something of value to exploit
those new laws, right? We're always going to we're going to have to pay large energy cost in one way
or another. But it's just kind of opening new new opening new trade routes to trade different
things is kind of how I think about it. Rather than exploits, I guess, you know, like with with
all quantum technology, we haven't like gotten some crazy exploit that allows us to hack into the
system and get like free, you know, energy for free or something. We've actually just opened up
new possibilities of trading huge amounts of energy in time to try to, you know, you know,
build new things and compute in different ways and stuff like that, maybe, but it's maybe it's
kind of semantic difference, I guess. No, no, I totally, I totally agree. But this is why I'm
thinking that like there, the problem with quantum is that we don't really understand what's going on.
Right? Like that's the main problem. We know how to compute the mathematics. But it's there's a
conceptual gap. And the more, you know, the more I think about observer theory about active inference
about this necessity of constructing reducible models by bounded observers, the more I'm certain
to think that like a lot of phenomena in quantum, like for instance, entanglement, you can really
nicely understand it as, you know, the sort of like Bayesian, from the Bayesian modeling perspective,
that you have us if systems interact, one system creates a model of another system. So it can do
some it can do something, you know, like I suddenly have a particle inside a quasi particle inside of
me that actually represents you. So that's how I can kind of affect your behavior in using a
non local correlation, because I have this quasi particle that allows me to exploit something in
you. Right. I know, for instance, you know, if we share a password or something, something like
that, right, I can say that in some in some completely arbitrary context, and you may completely
change your behavior, because you hear the special word where you're supposed to do something like
a sleeper agent, stuff like that, you know, that will be an example of a non local correlation.
Right. Yeah, yeah, definitely. Yeah. You know, interesting to think about.
And in like whether, you know, whether there are any kind of quantum correlations or anything like
that, you know, who knows? I mean, it's certainly been hard for us to create them experimentally,
but you know, but all right, well, I guess we'll try to start to transition towards the reading,
although, you know, I was hoping a few more people would come, but it's recorded. So
people will be able to listen back to the space afterwards. By the way, how's it going, Laura?
Thanks for coming. How did the reading go for you? Well, I kind of didn't do it, but
I'm happy to be here and listen. And I was also trying to read Wikipedia because
so I'm going to explain this wrong, but there's like this concept of, and apparently it's been
totally debunked, but it's, it's like zero point energy where something like a particle and an
antiparticle come into existence and annihilate. And oh gosh, I'm going to explain it wrong. Anyway,
I'll try to find the explanation of it, but long story short, this is the type of thing that I think
Carpathia was alluding to when he was talking about finding an exploit in the system. And like I
said, this theory is, you know, or this idea of getting energy. And I guess the idea is something
like you're actually taking energy from like a parallel universe or something when you're doing
this. And, you know, if parallel universes exist, there's like, again, like none of this is even
like remotely real. But, but anyway, when you're talking about, I do remember that,
that moment where he was talking about exploiting loopholes and reality. And yeah,
anyway, I think the energy thing is one of them. The other thing I wanted to say,
when Christoph was talking about coarse grain versus fine grained explanations, I think that
something that's happening now that we're just like really beginning to appreciate is that
computation is expensive. And the reason why I bring it up that way is because like,
I don't think that it, it like was appreciated. And I think people think like, oh, you know,
we have so much because of Moore's law, we have like more access to computation, but it's just
like, it's never really going to be enough. And so you have to find algorithms that, you know,
do you like a good enough coarse graining of the things that don't matter? And so that way they
can focus, you know, more compute on finer things that do matter and figuring out which is which is
really important. You can't just like brute force everything. It's not possible. Yeah, absolutely.
Actually, yeah, two things to say in response to that. First, on the point about like, you know,
computation is expensive. It's yeah, it's hugely important because at least like from the
background of when I was in grad school, you know, all the code I wrote was research code. It was
something I'd run on my laptop to get some plots and then send to my advisor or whatever. And often
those codes will be written in a very inefficient way. And, and, you know, whatever if it takes
hours or days to run is what it is. But now, you know, I'm working in a setting where we write,
you know, code for production. So it won't just be running on one machine and be running on many
machines. Stuff that runs on the client side could potentially be running on a very large
number of machines, right? And so you have to think about when you write, you know, come up with
algorithms, even at the lowest level of like deriving algorithms mathematically, you have to
imagine that these things are being scaled up to, you know, potentially millions and millions of
people or something like that. And that's like, yeah, one of the reasons why I'm so interested
in energy efficient computing, because like, even if we were just to kind of raise like,
if, you know, everyone around the world was kind of living at, you know, using technology at the
same standard as kind of, you know, how, how maybe, you know, we are, it would be a huge amount of
energy. So it's kind of difficult to imagine, you know, how we get to like the future where
everyone's able to use technology and things need to get a lot more efficient. So that's,
yeah, one of the reasons I'm super interested in this like thermodynamic computing stuff.
And yeah, I thought that zero point energy was a great analogy or a great example of like,
what would it mean to have like an exploit of the law of physics? I think as I kind of remember
what that's about is that for like a classical like mass on a spring or a harmonic oscillator,
it can have an energy of exactly zero, because it's kinetic energy can be zero, it can just
be sitting there motionless. Whereas for like the corresponding quantum mass on a spring,
because of the uncertainty principle, it can't be, you know, the uncertainty principle says if
you know where it is, then you don't know what its momentum is. And so either you don't know where
it is, or you don't know how fast it's going kind of one or the other. And so either has to have
some potential energy or some kinetic energy. And there's like a lowest amount of possible
energy can have, which is like one half Planck's constant or something. So in the thing about
it, though, that's like, it kind of misses the point of, it missed the whole point of thermodynamics,
right? That like energy we can actually use is like thermodynamic free energy. It's not just
energy period. So while there's, yeah, there's all this energy out there in theory,
that it's not energy that can, it's not energy that's really available to you,
do anything useful, I think, it's kind of the catch with the free energy stuff. But I remember,
I used to play this game, it was like a famous game made by the company Valve called Half-Life 2,
I don't know if any of you know it, but they had a gun in that game that you could use called the
free energy gun or something, and it could like pick objects up and throw them around and stuff.
It just, you know, didn't have to, you didn't have to recharge the batteries. So I imagine that's
like what the kind of stuff you'd be able to do if you had the free, you know, if you could harness
free energy somehow. Yeah, I thought that was a really good example actually. Okay, well, I guess
we'll kind of like get started a little bit with the reading. So like the first part of this
of this week's was like starting on chapter four or like page 64 on crystal lattices.
So by the way, do you guys have access to like the PDF of the book?
Okay, cool. Okay, well, I guess a good place to start, right, is like what is a lattice? Like what
is a, yeah, they call it a Brevet lattice after this French guy Brevet, B-R-A-V-A-I-S.
But the lattice is like just this very simple concept of a kind of an array of points in
three dimensional space that has this property that whichever point you're looking at,
it, you know, if you imagine you're sitting at some point in this array, it looks the same no
matter which point you're sitting at. So for example, you could think about a simple cubic
lattice. It's called a simple cubic lattice, and it's probably the most simple one to even think
about. And it's just, if you just imagine you took a cube, well, okay, so yeah, you take a cube and
you just pack a bunch of cubes into a box so that, you know, each cube has another cube sitting on
each side of it basically. And at the point that the vertices are at the corners of those cubes,
that's actually, that's the important part. Those are all points called the lattice points.
And so the lattice is actually those points at the corner of the cube. And so you have just
this regular array that if you take one step in either the x, y, or the z direction, you get back
to another point on the lattice or another lattice point. And you can imagine that if you are sitting
at one of these, if it goes, it goes forever, you know, it goes infinitely in every direction.
So if you were sitting at one of these points in the lattice, you wouldn't have any way of knowing
like which point you were at. None of the points looks any different from, from any others kind
of. So that's kind of the definition, one definition, he actually gives two definitions,
a and b. So that was a, the array of points that looks the same. And then b was, well, how do you,
I like b better actually, because it's kind of constructive. It tells you how to make a lattice
mathematically. And what you do is you pick three vectors in space, right? a1, a2, and a3. So each
of those is a three-dimensional vector, a three-dimensional direction with, with a magnitude.
And then you, you, you pick some integers, n1, n2, and n3. These are like positive integers,
like one, you know, they could be one, two, three, four, whatever. And then you just multiply each
of your vectors, a1, a2, or three. You take each of those and you multiply it by, by an integer,
and then you add those vectors together. And that gives you kind of a point in space. And then if
you try that for every, actually the n1's, the integers can go negative, they can also be zero,
sorry, they, I said they are positive, but they, they aren't, they, they can be positive, negative,
or zero. And so you try every possible combination of, of those integers. And remember, there's
infinitely many of those combinations. And you try every possible combination, and this gives you
this infinite array of points in space. So that was kind of like the definition of the lattice.
Yeah, were there any thoughts about that? Like, or questions about what the lattice is,
or anything like that, or Brevet lattices? Okay, so that was, I guess that was reasonably clear.
But I think they give an interesting, they give a nice example of like something that
isn't a Brevet lattice, which is if you can see this figure 4.3, this honeycomb,
this is not a Brevet lattice. And did anybody have any kind of, yeah, anyone who want to try to
take a stab at explaining why this honeycomb is not a Brevet lattice?
All right, I'm going to have to call on you guys. All right, Kristoff, what do you,
what do you think about this honeycomb? Does it look like a Brevet lattice?
Oh, hello, Kristoff, are you there?
Okay, maybe not. All right, well, Laura, I don't know, did you, can you see the figure 4.3,
the honeycomb? Okay,
figure 2, 4.3. Oh, no, that's figure 4. This is so confusing. Oh, I see, that's
equation 4.3, figure 4.6, okay, so. I was on, sorry, I was on page 66, at least in my day.
No, no, that's correct. Oh,
right. Yeah, so what about this, you know, any, any thoughts like why, why it isn't a Brevet
lattice, this honeycomb? So I don't know, like, the real reason, but looking at it makes me think
of something that tessellates rather than forms a crystal. All right, well, okay, so yeah, so,
well, I'm not sure, yeah, I honestly don't know what tessellates, yeah, what is the definition
of tessellate? Tessellate, huh? Well, it's like a repeating pattern. Oh, right.
It's a natural pattern that, like, all interacts with itself. I see. Well, yeah, that's, I guess
that's correct in the sense that it does, right, it does look like a tessellate, it tiles the plane,
so I guess that, that much is true. As far as I think like the way, like, the technical reason
of, like, why this is not a Brevet lattice is that we can find, like, two points here from which
it looks different. So if you go, like, if you go on your computer and you see the point P and you
zoom way into the point P, so you just see these three lines, right? One line is going to the right,
another one's kind of going up into the left, another one's kind of going down into the left,
right? So you see those three lines coming out of the point P.
And then those point to the kind of three nearest neighbors, like the three nearest lattice
points, where if we went and we zoomed way in on the point R, now we have one line going to the
left and one line going up into the right and another going down to the right. So in other words,
if we, like, basically zoom way in and imagine you were sitting on the point P versus sitting on
the point R, your surroundings would kind of look different, like, if you were on those two different
points. Right, yeah, so that's how you know it's not a Brevet lattice, because in a Brevet lattice,
no matter what point you're at, your surroundings would look exactly the same.
Oh, okay, that makes sense. Right, so if we compare it to, let's see, they give one,
an example one that is a Brevet lattice, like figure 4.1 on the previous page, here, like,
if you're sitting at any of these points, your surroundings will look exactly the same in figure
4.1, actually. Okay, so that was the definition. I think that basically covers, like, what is,
like, the kind of the core of the idea of the Brevet lattice, because that's kind of confusingly,
there's a lot of things that look, as you put it, like, tessellate the space or, like, are repetitive,
but aren't lattices. And then, like, if you, of course, there can be, like, you know,
materials that have a strict structure that looks more like 4.3, and if you want to describe
something like that mathematically, you basically add, like, something else on top of a lattice.
So there's, like, basically a lattice that includes some of the points in 4.3, and then you add
something else called a basis, which basically, like, covers all the other points, and it turns
out to be a useful way of thinking about it, I guess. So they talk about a few important ones.
There's one called the FCC, or, well, actually, first they talk about the BCC, or body-centered,
body-centered cubic lattice. And I guess that's the one where you imagine you have a cube with a
point at each corner of the cube, and then there's also a point in the center of the cube. So it's,
like, a little bit more complicated than the simple cubic, where you would just have points at the
corners of the cube. And it's, the interesting thing about this is, like, it's not, like,
at first, totally obvious, I think, that this actually is a Brevet lattice, like, because if
you're at one of the corners of the cube versus being at the point in the middle of the cube,
like, maybe that would look different, but it turns out that it actually is the same.
So it does turn out to be a Brevet lattice where, whether you're at the corner or whether you're
in the center of the cube, your surroundings are actually just going to look exactly the same.
So that's, like, the BCC, and then there's also the FCC, where this is also a cube where you have
added a point at each corner of the cube, but then in the center, in the middle of each, like,
face of the cube, each side, you've added a point there, but you don't add a point in the middle.
That one also turns out to be a Brevet lattice. And so those ones are pretty important because
there's a lot of different, like, metals and materials that end up having those lattice structures,
whereas the simple cubic is actually really rare. You know, you would think that would be kind of,
like, the most simple, maybe that would be pretty common, but it turns out you don't really see the
simple cubic lattice much in nature at all, except for some really weird, like, special cases.
So, yeah, I don't know. Any other thoughts or questions on maybe, like, the FCC or BCC or anything
like that? Okay, well, let's see. So I guess I'll just summarize another part, which is on, like,
what is a primitive unit cell? So when you have this lattice, right, the lattice is made up by
the points. It is a set of points that extends infinitely through three-dimensional space and
has this repetitive structure. Now, if we want to talk about, like, kind of a portion of space
within this framework, we introduced this new thing called a primitive unit cell. And what a
primitive unit cell is, is it's a, first of all, it's a region of space with a finite volume,
and then it has to meet kind of two conditions to be a primitive unit cell. So first of all,
when you take this unit cell and you translate it through the lattice vectors, so remember those
lattice, the vectors that kind of define the lattice, because the point, like, you get from
one lattice point to another by adding up some combination of lattice vectors. And it's also
true that for the unit cells, if I take a unit cell and I translate it by some combination of
lattice vectors, then it will perfectly fall on top of another unit cell, and they'll be exactly
the same, basically. And so they give a few examples in Figure 4.10 of, like, primitive unit cells.
So that was, right, so I guess the two things that had to satisfy were, first of all, when you
translate it through space, it, by all of the lattice vectors, it totally fills up space,
and then it doesn't, it doesn't actually, like, overlap with other ones. It either falls exactly
on top of them, or it doesn't coincide with them at all. And so this is just a way of, like, yeah,
tiling space, basically, or kind of a tessellation, as you put it, that's, you have exactly one of
these per lattice point. And so there, and there's one lattice, there's one lattice point in each
unit cell, and each unit cell has one lattice point. So the interesting point about them is that
they're not, like, there's not a unique way to come up with, like, the primitive unit cells. Like,
there's many different ways of doing it, and that's what they kind of illustrated in Figure 4.10,
is, like, all of these different ways of kind of carving up space is equally good, or at least is
equally a primitive unit cell. And maybe they're not all equally good. There might be some, you
know, that are, that are better than others, or more useful than others. And the one that's, I
think, is kind of the coolest one, you know, it ends up being the most useful in a lot of ways,
is what's called the Wigner-Seitz unit cell. And the Wigner-Seitz unit cell is actually pretty
easy to find. You just, you take a lattice point, and you find all the points in space that are
closer to that point than to any other, right? So if we called one point A, right, and then there's
some other points near it, like B and C, if we look at any point in space, you know, we could look
at its distances to A and B and C. And for some points, the closest lattice point will be A.
And those points are in the Wigner-Seitz unit cell. And the interesting thing about the Wigner-Seitz
unit cell is that, like, it doesn't depend on any particular coordinate system to define it. Like,
its definition is this, like, totally kind of pure geometrical thing that's just based on the
lattice itself. And so I kind of like that definition because it doesn't, like, actually
introduce any coordinate system. And so it ends up having, like, all the same symmetries as the
lattice itself are kind of inherited by this Wigner-Seitz unit cell, actually. So that was the
Wigner-Seitz unit cell. Let's see. Any questions about that or comments?
So that's interesting, but it depends on the, effectively, how you measure distance in space.
So you have to make some assumptions about the space itself. So you're just sort of assuming
you clearly on space here, right? Uh-huh. Right. Yeah, I guess that's true, right. We, yeah,
we've assumed that you clearly in space. Yeah, let me think about that. Right, because when we...
But I just want to make an observation that, like, this whole process of coming up with
this primitive unit cells, it seems to me that, like, it's almost like trying to turn something
that is, you know, this Cartesian space, the stage for action, into something that is much
more like a graph. Hmm, interesting. I see. Well, yeah, I guess that's true in a way. You know what's
that? What actually makes it even more like a graph is the concept that's called the coordination
number. So when you look at, so again, when you look at any lattice point, it has some nearest
neighbors, right? It has some other lattice points that are closer to it than any other.
And some of those nearest neighbors will be the same distance away. And so you basically,
you look at, like, what's the closest point to any given lattice point, and maybe that closest
point is a distance of d, and then you count how many points are there that are a distance of d.
And the number of neighbors it has at the distance d is then going to be called the
coordination number. So that does kind of, you know, create a graph, I guess, in that each,
node has its kind of nearest neighbors in a way. Interesting. Yeah. And now I guess, like, you could,
there are certain changes to the metric you could do that would change this a lot, right? And it's
interesting to think about what properties of the crystal don't change under some, you know,
change to the metric, I guess. Like, for one thing, kind of the topology of the crystal isn't
going to change, like, which things are next to which other, which lattice points are next to
which other lattice points shouldn't change too much with, you know, unless you do something really
crazy with the metric, I think. But yeah, I guess, like, the bigger sites in itself might change.
I wonder if it would, it might still have, like, if you look at, like, figure 4.14, they have an
example of a Wigner-Seitz unit cell. And I wonder if, like, if you did change the metric, it might
still have kind of the same general, it might be the same kind of, what's the word, polygon,
but it might just, like, be stretched in some way. But it's interesting because it's kind of
important, like, not just, like, its actual proportions, but, like, how many corners it has
and things like that. So some of those properties might not change too much, even a distorted space.
I'm just trying to say that from, you know, the perspective of, like, how I tend to think
about everything, this sounds like, this whole process of coming up with these models, it sounds
like, basically, you know, you're starting with this space and we're trying to just carve it up
in some way that we have these abstractions that we talked about earlier that you can move them
around and they don't change, the interfaces don't change. Yeah, yeah, definitely. I mean, right,
like, the core kind of simplification here, I guess, is, like, the periodicity, right, of, like,
just having this, like, structure that's periodic in this, like, special way. And of course, in
reality, like, the crystal, it is, like, periodic when you look at it down in the tiniest, like,
microscopic level, right? But when you take, like, an actual chunk of metal in your hand,
it doesn't look the same. It's like, it usually doesn't occur in that form where you see these,
like, crystalline shapes, just because the actual period, the scale in which you would actually see
that periodicity is, like, really, really small. And on a larger scale, you have a bunch of little
crystals that are all kind of mashed together in some way. And so the large-scale thing is not
really periodic. So, yeah, it definitely is. This is, like, a kind of simplification where we're
saying, well, imagine that the bulk material kind of had this, the same exact, like, structure
as a really tiny part of the bulk material, I guess, which, interestingly, also, like, ends up,
like, giving you pretty good approximations a lot of the time, I think.
So, yeah, so that was, like, the Bravais lattice and the Wigner-Seitz unit cell.
Yeah, it was an interesting definition, but not, like, totally motivated at this point. I think
we don't really start using it till a little bit later. But let's see. They also, they introduced
something called the diamond structure, which is not a Bravais lattice. And, like, some points from
sitting at some points in the lattice, the surroundings look different. Or it's not a
lattice, but it's a structure. Sitting at some point in the structure, the surrounding looks
different. But you could think of it as, like, and I think they say you can think of it as an
FCC lattice, but where you've also added another point, like, kind of, that's translated, like,
from each lattice point, you've added another point that's translated that displacement vector of,
like, 1, 1, 1, like, 1 in each direction x, y, and z. So that's, like, this diamond structure,
which ends up being important because a lot of materials have that structure. So I think that
that's, like, basically it for this chapter, chapter four. Those are, like, all the important
concepts, really. And then in chapter five, they start with something cool, which is the
definition of the reciprocal lattice. So let's see. So, yeah, Kristoff, I feel like you might
be familiar with this. Have you, like, you know, like, the idea of, like, vectors and co-vectors?
Only vaguely.
Okay, all right. Well, so this is, like, kind of the, I guess, the way they might think about this
and, like, you know, differential geometry or something like that. They don't use the word
co-vectors in this book. But so, right. So a vector is an element of a vector space,
right, where you have these, you have these things, you have a commutative addition operation,
and then you have, like, a scalar multiplication operation, and you have an identity, you have
an origin. And then a co-vector is, like, an operator that acts on that space and maps.
It's a function from the vector space to the real numbers. So it's input as a vector and it's
output as a scalar, a real number. And given a basis, given, like, or given any set of vectors,
like a set of n vectors, you can come up with something that's called a dual basis, which is
a set of co-vectors. And the important thing about the dual basis is that each dual basis element,
like, picks out one basis element, picks out one vector. When you apply it to one vector,
it gives you an output of one. And when you apply it to any of the, any of the other vectors,
its output is zero. And so it's like, this is useful when you have, like, a non-orthogonal
basis, basically. When you have a more orthogonal basis, everything is easy and it is its own dual
basis. But when you have a set of vectors that aren't, like, all orthogonal to each other,
it's, you have to come up with a dual basis, basically, in order to, like, pick out individual
basis vectors. But the defining, like, equation of the, of what's called the reciprocal lattice,
which is really the same thing as a dual basis, is equation, where is it, is equation 5.4. So
here, a sub j, these are what are called the primitive lattice vectors. And b sub i, those
are what they're defining as the, like, the reciprocal lattice vectors. And those are the
dual vectors to the, the a sub j. And you can see that, because in this equation,
when you take the dot product of b sub i with a sub j, you get zero if i is not the same as j,
and you get two pi if they're the same. So I guess up to that factor of two pi, it's like
the exact same thing as the dual basis. Right. So it's kind of like a set of functions that
allows you to effectively orthogonalize a basis. Yep. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah. So yeah, these
kind of things are super useful whenever you have, like, a non orthogonal basis. And because you have,
like, here, like some crystal where the crystal might kind of look like a, what's the word,
parallel piped when you look at the little unit cells, it's useful to basically introduce this
kind of dual basis. Yeah. In the sort of broader sense, I think, in some sense, the function of
neural networks is basically to do something like this for arbitrary, arbitrary basis, like there's
some, you know, this sort of orthogonalization and linearization seem to be the goal of
intelligent systems. Because once you do that, then you can actually start making sense out of a
system. If you have bases that are not orthogonal, it becomes very difficult to think about them.
And here, we're looking at this just from the linear perspective. So it's kind of like very
microscopic, but neural networks kind of do it at, so to say, at scale for nonlinear,
nonlinear phenomena that we're trying to model. But ultimately, they're trying to come up with
representations that are as orthogonal and as linear as possible.
Right. Yeah, yeah, I think that's kind of right. You can think of it almost like as an encoder,
decoder kind of thing where if I have like three numbers and I want to encode them in a vector,
like the simplest way is to use an orthogonal basis and come up with a vector x, y, z, where x,
y, and z are the three numbers I had. But right, then I could make it more complicated where I could
do x times a1 plus y times a2 plus z times a3, where now a1, a2, and a3 are three kind of weird
vectors in arbitrary directions. And then you might ask, well, how can I recover x, y, and z
from that vector I've constructed? And the way you do that is using the dual basis. The dual
basis allows you to get out the original things you put in. So I think you can, and right, so here,
because this is like the simple, like this is just linear combination. So it's really easy.
And then in some like neural network architectures, you might be able to like kind of encode things
in the latent space and then try to extract out, you know, something from that kind of.
Exactly. You have the same kind of thing here, encoder, decoder, but here it's constructed
geometrically. Yeah. Yep. Yeah, I see. Yeah, that's an interesting way to look at it. Yeah,
I definitely hadn't thought about that actually. That's kind of cool. I think it's a very simple
conceptual way to think about it, right? Like, because you can get lost into the, I always used
to get lost in the details of what linear algebra is trying to do with the, all this vocabulary,
build up around structures. When you think about all this is just essentially, you know, encoder,
decoder, then it's like suddenly you're like, oh, that's, that's actually really easy to conceptualize.
Yeah. Yeah, that's really good, actually. Yeah. So like, I guess you could think of like the
basis and dual basis is like, it's almost like a dictionary in programming where you can store
things in the dictionary. But it's a weird dictionary where the keys you use to enter
things in the dictionary are different from the keys that you use to read things from the dictionary,
basically. So like, for an orthogonal basis, that would be the same key. But for non orthogonal
basis, you use the basis vectors to write to the dictionary, and then you use the dual basis
vectors to read from the dictionary. Yeah, actually, I really like that analogy. That's a good way of
thinking about it. Okay, cool. So, oh, and then another nice property of this reciprocal is that
the reciprocal of the reciprocal lattice is, again, the original lattice. So it's like,
something kind of, well, I forget what they call it, involution. Yeah, this is a transformation
that when you do it twice, you get back to the original kind of space. So you can think of this
kind of dual space as mirror image of the original, not mirror image, but like this,
you know, underground image of the original space that is a different way to look at things, kind of.
If you ever saw the show, like, Stranger Things, you could think of it like that.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, right now. So in solid state physics, they call it the direct lattice and
the reciprocal lattice that's basically like that, the normal world in the upside down.
Yeah, but you know, that's that phenomenon of like, there being these dualities, this is exactly
what I was talking about earlier, that seems to be super duper fundamental that you have this,
like, on one hand, you have objects, right? On the other hand, you have functions, right? There's
always, there's always this duality, and there's a, there's a different kind of beast that lives
in one space, and there's just the other, and there's somehow, to me, there are somehow orthogonal
in some weird way, you know? Right. Yeah. Yeah, definitely. In all those, like,
commutation diagrams you see in math, where it's like, you go down to like the different lower
level, and then you go across, and then you go back up. And that's kind of the way, yeah, I think
about these dualities, right? There are a way to get, there are a way to get from point A to point B,
but instead of trying to go directly in the space you're in, you go to some other space, and then
go, and then you go back to the space you were in originally, kind of. Yeah. All right, so those
were the reciprocal lattices. They give a few examples, like, so those lattices I was talking
about earlier, the FCC and the BCC, they're reciprocals of each other. So, like, if you have
an FCC lattice, the reciprocal lattice is the BCC lattice, and then vice versa. So that's kind of
a neat little factoid, I guess, about those lattices. They talk about lattice planes,
Miller indices. These aren't too important, at least at the level where, you know, I mean,
unless you want to get, like, super into X-ray crystallography, the Miller indices might be
useful. But yeah, well, I guess the next chapter is about this X-ray crystallography stuff.
And this is, like, how they're actually able to, like, kind of, like, measure the structures of
crystals and, like, figure out through measurements what the structure of a crystal actually is.
And it's kind of cool how it works, I guess. They talk about, like, in the book, they talk about
two different, like, formulations of the X-ray crystallography, one that Bragg came up with,
and the other that Fun Lalla came up with, I guess, and they first, like, start with a Bragg one.
But this is, like, a pretty well-known thing in physics, this, like, Bragg diffraction. It's just
the idea that when you have, like, a, you have a series, you have a bunch of mirrors that are
kind of parallel to each other, but light can also kind of, like, go through the mirrors.
And so when you send in light, it reflects off of, like, all of these mirrors that are parallel to
each other. And then if the, when it reflects, the light can kind of destructively interfere,
right, because the light is a wave. And so if the mirrors are the right distance apart,
when the light reflects all the peaks of one wave will overlap with the troughs of another wave,
whereas if they're another distance apart, all the peaks will kind of align with each other
when it reflects. And this also depends on the angle that the light reflects at. So that's what's,
what's going on. Figure 6.1 is kind of looking at, when light reflects off of these two parallel
mirrors, at what angle will you have, like, destructive versus constructive interference?
And that's, like, really the key to investigating the structure of a crystal, is to know, like,
how that Bragg diffraction works, because then you can kind of send in light at a bunch of different
angles, and you'll see at some angles you get, you see a reflection, and at other angles you
don't see any reflection, because there's that destructive interference. So that's the basic
idea of that, like, Bragg diffraction thing. Let's see. And then there's, there's another,
like, formulation of it, which is, like, the Von Lauer formulation, but they're equivalent,
like, the Bragg diffraction and the Von Lauer diffraction are, like, just equivalent ways of
looking at the same thing. So, like, for Bragg diffraction, this key, the key equation is equation
6.2, n lambda, where lambda is the wavelength, and n is, like, any integer. So any integer
number times the wavelength is equal to 2d times the sine of theta, and d is the distance between
parallel lattice planes, and theta is the angle that the reflection is at. So that's, like, the key,
like, this equation, when this equation is true, you'll see a reflection, when it's not,
you don't really see one. And then there's, like, another way of looking at it, which is the Von Lauer
kind of picture, which I guess is summarized by which equation here. I think it's, like,
equation 6.5 that is kind of formative in terms of the k vector of the light that's reflected,
transmitting that incident and leaving the surface, where k is, like, coming in and k prime is going
out, and it's looking at the difference between those. And the k vector is, like, basically the
momentum of the light, and so this is the condition, this is just another way of looking at the
condition that you'll actually see, you'll see a reflection or not, basically. So yeah,
any thoughts or kind of questions on the crystallography stuff?
None for me.
Okay. Yeah, yeah, I didn't find this part, like, super interesting, you know, honestly, I mean,
it's useful experimentally, but it doesn't tell you much about, like, the actual behavior of the
material, so it's just kind of, it's more a kind of historical thing of how they actually figured
all this out, like, how they figure out that the crystal looked like this at a microscopic level, I
guess. Now, chapter 7 is, like, probably the most, maybe the most, like, pure math in the book,
because it's, like, kind of talking about group theory, and, like, groups of
symmetries that a lattice has. So, of course, like, that lattice can be translated by a lattice
vector, and that's a symmetry. That was actually the definition of the lattice, was that, like,
well, essentially the definition was that you translate it by all these lattice vectors,
and you get back the same thing. But there's other symmetries you can do, like,
you can, sometimes you can rotate the lattice, and you get back the same thing as well.
And so, it turns out, like, well, you have, like, an infinite number of
lattices you can have. There's only a finite number of symmetry groups that the lattice can have,
and so that's, like, how they actually classify them, is by what the symmetry group of the lattice is.
And it's kind of cool that there's, there's seven of what they call point groups,
which are, the point group is, like, the set of rotations you can do to a lattice that leaves it
the same. And the, and then there's 14 of what they call space groups. And a space group is when
you're allowed to do a rotation and a translation. And so they're, and so those are basically,
you can think of it as, like, the important thing are the space groups, like, these are
all of the symmetries the lattice can have. And then those can be grouped into point groups.
So, some space groups are members of the same point group. And so, for example, they talk about,
like, the cubic, the point group of the cubic lattice and the point group of, like, tetragonal
lattices. And then they break down, like, what are the space groups, like, within those. But,
yeah, so that's just kind of a point on, like, how you classify them, which may be interesting
from, like, a mathematical perspective, I don't know. That is way over my head in terms of maths.
Yeah. Yeah, honestly, yeah, mine too. I haven't done too much. I mean, a little bit of group here,
but it's, yeah, actually, like, figuring out, like, how do they figure out that there are only 14
is, yeah, I wouldn't know how to do that, honestly. But so, you know, the main gist of what I'm getting
out of these couple of chapters is basically, so we have space. There is this assumption that
all kinds of things can happen to space. So we figure out a way of partitioning it in such a way
that we define some interfaces between little regions of it. And then it turns out that by
adding these constraints about how we are going to put partition space with, in such a way that
the interfaces hold, there is only a finite way in which these things compose in such a way that
the structure is preserved. So suddenly you have something that had basically infinite degrees of
freedom, Cartesian empty space, where, you know, things can just float around willy-nilly. And
suddenly you have something that actually has still a lot of degrees of freedom, but it's a
more defined structure that you can start investigating properties of, like this periodicity
and so on and so forth. Yeah, yeah, definitely. And I think what jumps out to me is that the
definition of the lattice was, like, super simple. Like, it's just pick three vectors in space and
then do every single translation you could think of using those, using any combination of those
three vectors. And it seems like, you know, no matter what three vectors you pick, you get something
that's kind of similar, right? Like, it feels like, you know, you can kind of twist the thing a little
bit or kind of shear it in different directions or extract it in different directions. But it feels
like, well, we're just kind of generating an array of points in three dimensions. And so the thing
that to me is kind of surprising is that out of the map, there pops out, well, actually, not all
there are kind of different categories of lattices that in this way of generating them,
you can end up with. And there turned out to be these exactly 14 special categories of them,
which to me was like pretty surprising and interesting that like, even though it feels
like this kind of homogeneous and simple way of generating things through linear combinations,
you end up with these 14 kind of families, I guess. But yeah. Yeah, right. That's quite
surprising because it feels like almost as if you had like this continuous space of
deformations from one lattice to another, like if I jiggle the vectors just a little bit,
why would I fall into one category versus another? They're almost identical quote unquote.
Yeah, no, exactly, exactly. I think the key to it is that you can lose the symmetry basically,
right? Like you can start out with three vectors, like you can start out with the orthogonal basis
of just the x, y, and z unit vectors. And that's like perfectly symmetrical. And so there's a
bunch of symmetry operations you can do that map it back onto itself. But then if you just make
one of those vectors a tiny bit shorter, now you've lost that symmetry because some operations won't,
you know, preserve the symmetry anymore. And so I think that's basically where it kind of comes
from is that you have this hierarchy of different symmetries and doing different deformations,
you lose some symmetry basically. That's a good insight. Yeah. Thanks for highlighting that.
That's really, really interesting. Yeah. So it's kind of cool. And it's neat,
just I guess, because like just because the way that the solids like form on this microscopic
level, they'll tend to like to form into a certain symmetry, and they'll be really,
really symmetrical at that bottom level. But then sometimes with the right combination of atoms,
they like to form in a way where you're missing some important, you're missing some symmetry or
something like that. So yeah, it's kind of neat about this classification thing, I guess.
Isn't necessarily like the art of creating some, you know, I don't know if it's the right term,
but like composite materials is basically add a little bit of some other material,
and that would be essentially breaking, potentially breaking some symmetry so that you
get interesting properties out of that. Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly. Right. So yeah, when you add some,
yeah, when you, and then that's like when they make like semiconductors and stuff, I think they
they basically like dope semiconductor devices, they'll dope, you know, silken with some other
atom, basically add a little bit of impurities. And then, and yeah, you probably, well,
I think like with the impurities, though, that's not like those are probably things that just like
end up like here and there, but like are not like all over the lattice space, like in other words,
there wouldn't be with one of those impurities in every single primitive unit cell. So that kind
of makes it like, you know, a little bit less ordered, because you have all these little,
you know, defects, I guess, or little impurities in various places, whereas like it's more kind
of at the molecular level, if I choose the right molecule to like build my lattice out of that
molecule might like to build structures with a certain symmetry or might like structures of,
you know, less symmetry or something like that. Yeah, if you have time at the end of the space,
remind me to tell you about one thing from this consciousness conference about
electrical versus electrochemical neurons. For sure. Yeah. Well, actually, yeah, we could,
we could do kind of an interview, I guess, to talk about that, because that sounds pretty
interesting. So, yeah, do you want to just do that now? Okay, so one of the speakers, there was
this panel about, you know, functionalism, whether it's a valid approach. So this is the idea that
like, you know, if you have a causal structure that implements a given function, then it is the
same as another causal structure that implements an event function. So if you take the functionalist
approach to consciousness, then something like substrate independence becomes possible.
Consciousness of machines becomes possible simply so like if it, if it walks like a duck,
walks like a duck, looks like a duck, if it's functionally equivalent to a duck, it is a duck.
And one of the panelists was in a symposium, he was, he was arguing about the sort of
privileged nature of meat and biology. And he was doing that by making an argument.
It was kind of interesting, he was, he made this argument that about the similarity of
electrical and electrochemical neurons, that there was a paper, I think, from the 1940s,
that showed that you can, if you have a purely electrical, electrical neuron, you can still
do inhibition with that, that you don't need the electrochemical neurons to, to have this like
gap to, to do inhibition through, you know, the chemical processes.
Sorry, what does that mean, inhibition?
So, you know, in a, in a, in a digital neural network, you have like that, you can have positive
and negative weights, right? So when neurons fire, the chemicals released into the environment
inhibit other neurons from firing, they prevent them from, from firing at the same time.
So there, there is like a second layer of propagation of the signals, so to speak,
that alters the environment of other neurons, and then they may not fire in case of some,
some of their neighbors firing, even though the electrical potentials around them are high enough
for them to be activated. So what I found interesting about this is that I think it made me think that
he, so, so he was saying that there might be something special about bi, living biological
systems because these two kinds of neurons are equivalent. But that struck me as a sort of,
that you can do inhibition with electrical neurons. That struck me as a kind of an interesting,
interesting, wrong conclusion from, from, from the data, that whether, even if you can do inhibition
with electrical neurons alone, the electrochemical structure probably removes more degrees of
freedom. So it's kind of like, you know, creating something a bit like those, those symmetric
groups or something like that, that even, even if, in principle, if you can do it with electrical
neurons alone, there is probably going to be some kind of nth order interference from just being
immersed in the same electric field that, you know, it's gonna, it's good, you're never gonna
be able to get rid of, that you're always receiving noise from, from everything else.
But if you add electrochemical junction, and you can find this, you know, electrical firing
process that way, then you're sort of breaking that, breaking that symmetry. You're adding more
structure that is, that is giving you insulation from what's happening, you know, in other
electrical signals around you. So it's struck me as something kind of, kind of interesting and
important. So like that might be, that might be basically the function of the reason why you
have it is precisely because you want to, it's kind of like adding those, adding those impurities
to the material, right? You want to prevent chatter from one part of the material, the dependence of
one part of the material to another, just by adding something that will, that will keep the
signal localized. I see. So it's kind of what you're saying, the idea is that kind of like,
while you can do inhibition with just electrical neurons, and honestly, I don't really know what
electrical neurons are, but while you might be able to do inhibition with electrical neurons,
that might also kind of create some side effects, because like you don't have enough degrees of
freedom to like specify the behavior you want without creating additional, you know, changes
or something. Yeah, exactly. Think about it as a MLP versus CNN in digital neural networks, right?
A multilayer perceptron is a universal function approximator. And yet it's really difficult
to train it to do the, on a classification task compared to a convolutional neural network. And
convolutional neural network effectively removes the dependence of, you know, some output neurons
and some of the input neurons. You're just kind of like, trim it by adding this requirement for
translation equivalence, but you're effectively constraining a receptive field, layer to layer.
So it's something similar that you need this, you add these constraints. So it's like you
remove degrees of freedom effectively, right? But that allows you to express deeper in some
sense a richer, richer set of computations, because you don't have kind of like this,
a quote unquote, destructive or constructive interference from, from neighboring neurons.
Oh, right. I see. Yeah, right. I see. And that, yeah, when you have kind of,
in the convolutional neural network has more symmetry, and also like fewer kind of connections
per activation, I guess. So it has kind of less complexity compared to a MLP that has the same
number of activations, basically. I see. So yeah, there's this kind of relationship between,
yeah, symmetry and complexity. I see. That's, that's pretty interesting. It seems to run,
it seems to run pretty deep. Right. That you, you remove some symmetries and you can get,
you can get some really interesting, interesting complexity as a result.
Right. Remove or add. Sorry, I'm not, I'm not super well versed with this lingo. I guess remove.
Yeah. Yeah. And I guess like, yeah, to try to like, yeah, kind of make an analogy with the
crystals in some sense, like, like changing a crystal structure from like, cubic to kind of a
rectangular prism, and that like removes the symmetry. It kind of, well, it adds complexity in
a way, but it's different from like adding a bunch of other molecules. Like it just kind of,
yeah, reduces the symmetry of it. That might be kind of like taking a convolutional neural network
and saying, instead of having kernels that are like square, I'm going to have kernels that are
rectangular or something like that. You know, I wonder, you know, that would, I guess, change
kind of the equivalence properties of it in some way. Yeah. And there are, there is some work that
makes them, I think hexagonal and it has to do, there are some extensions like that, but they're
beyond, they'll be on my pay grade. But yeah, they do lead to interesting properties. Right.
Right. Yeah. And I guess like, yeah, you're never going to have like total, you have like kind of
symmetries by a 90 degree rotation, right? Because everything is pixels, but you don't have
symmetry by like kind of a, like other arbitrary rotations, which is kind of interesting. So
maybe with the hexagonal, you get a little bit like different rotational symmetries or something.
So, you know, the reason why I keep bringing this up is that I can't, I can't help, but I'm
starting to see this, this tradeoff everywhere. And I think that understanding this tradeoff
will yield some really interesting novel insight. Right. Yeah. Well, and what's really interesting
to me too is that like symmetries are also like fundamentally important in, in thermodynamics,
because when you like apply, well, when phase transitions happen, you often have like a spontaneous
like symmetry breaking, like where you like, let's say you have a cube, but it could be kind of
stretched into a parallel pipe bed, but it could stretch in like different directions or something
like that. Right. And so maybe like when, maybe when you lower the energy, in other words, like
lower the temperature, maybe it wants to, to stretch into a lower, you know, into a parallel
pipe bed, but has to kind of choose which way to go. And that's, and it's going to lose symmetry
as a result of that. And it's kind of hard to do that. Like it's kind of hard to lose symmetry
when you, when you have symmetry. And so that's like where kind of, I guess some of the energy,
you know, goes in, in these like phase transitions, which is kind of interesting, but
Yeah. Right. Yeah. So, so in there, it's kind of cool, because you can like these, these like,
like we were talking about how you have these like 14 separate families of symmetries. It's,
and that's just kind of an abstract mathematical thing. But then in physics, you can actually see
like the discrete, you know, kind of like discontinuous transition from one symmetry group
to another when you cross phase transitions. So they, they end up being like physical kind of
phenomena. It's kind of cool. Yeah. That's really cool. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. So that, yeah, that was, that was definitely, oh, actually, that there's one
of the question I wanted to ask about that. So yeah, so connecting it back to the thing you
were talking about, like the functional view of things, like David walks like a duck or whatever
it is a duck. So yeah, what's the relationship there, I guess? Well, these people have been
trying to make, in my opinion, in the very unsuccessfully, the argument that the functionalist
approach to understanding consciousness is bound to fail because there is something privileged
about the substrate that, you know, the fact that you're running on wet where matters.
And there's another dimension here, you know, people, people talk about this notion of mortal
versus immortal computation, the mortal computation is, you know, dies when the hardware dies and
the immortal computation lives on. That's the kind of Turing Turing computation on this abstract
machine. Okay. To me, you're basically saying that like, well, this argument in context of
consciousness is essentially saying that like, well, we believe in the quantum nature of consciousness
without using the word quantum, right? That effectively, a quantum state is the only thing
that we know of that cannot be copied. So if your consciousness is dependent on entirety of the
quantum state, if it's somehow generated by it, then obviously, you know, you can't extract it from
you and upload yourself into a computer. If on the other hand, you can distill, you know,
the causal structure that makes you you into an abstract form that's suitable to run on top of
a Turing machine, then so you have this immortal computation, then there is a possibility of
achieving substrate independence. And I think the mistake they make is that
a lot of these people, you know, somehow are married to the idea of what makes them them,
that I'm the kind of person who is blah, you know, I'm the kind of person who has a body and so on
so forth. Obviously, if my consciousness moves to a digital computer, I don't expect to have the
same experience that they have in my meat sack, right? So I'm not the meat sack. It's just how I
experience it. So I don't need to take all this detail with me to be me. I'm not my memories.
I'm not my thoughts. I'm not my ideas. I'm something else. I'm the watcher of all of this.
That is what really consciousness is, not any content of it. So they're basically without
saying so. In my opinion, this is either smuggling God or quantum theory into the
conversation about consciousness. Okay. Yeah. So one kind of point I wanted to make is that
to me, like the idea of this like functionalism that like, well, yeah, what is the thing,
you know, it just is defined by its kind of inputs and outputs, how it behaves. To me,
like this is kind of a, in time, this is like a backwards looking rather than forwards looking
approach. Because I think that like very frequently often, we've had kind of a collection of things
that appear to behave the same in every way. Like, for example, to connect to the book,
maybe we have different metals that have very similar conductivity. And so from people in,
you know, the 19th century, they would say, well, that functionally, they're the same. So these are
the same thing or something. But then later on in time, we figure out a new measurement to take.
And we see that they can be distinguished from each other. So I think like the functionalism,
it assumes like that you won't get new information later that does allow you to distinguish the
things, I guess. And so you kind of prematurely decide that these are the same because they
both walk like a duck, but I don't know how to actually distinguish them yet. So that's like,
yeah, that was one kind of point I wanted to make that the functionalism is kind of like
backwards looking. Not that that's wrong, but I just think that's like, because sometimes people
use like backwards looking as like a pejorative, but I just kind of literally, I think it's kind of
backwards looking in that. No, I understand. I think it's a very good point. Yeah. And then
I actually forgot everything I was going to say. I think it was related to what you're saying after
that. But yeah, I kind of forgot. It totally resonates that like, you know, basically what
you're saying is that we talked about this computational irreducibility. What you're really
saying is that if you take functionalist approach, you necessarily by virtue of only being able to
measure certain things, you extract a computationally reducible representation of the system. And that
system could have done some amazing things later down the line because of the irreducible properties
that you were not able to carry, right? And this goes back straight to quantum. You cannot copy the
quantum state. Right, right. Oh, yeah, that reminds me. Okay, I remember the other thing I was going
to say, which was that the question of like whether, you know, so you're saying like, well, if quantum
is if quantum phenomena are really important to like who we are fundamentally, right, like not the
things I've experienced, but who experienced them, then you won't be able to, you know, take into
measure a person's quantum state and upload it to the computer. And I think that that that makes
sense. And I also I think that like the question of like whether quantum phenomena are important to
like consciousness, or at least to thought, I guess, which is which is different. But I think
that that question probably can be answered within like the next like 50 years, that would kind of
be my my wild guess. Because I think that that's something that like, we basically know how we
know how to measure like we have kind of a program for know for like figuring out where
quantum phenomena are occurring, basically, in terms of kind of collective quantum phenomena
and entanglement and stuff like that. And I think like that's probably something
like we'll be able to measure. It really depends on like whether we'll be able to do kind of non
invasive measurements of that. But I would expect that to be basically answered. I think it's
something we can figure out. But yeah, I have no idea what the answer will be, but pretty exciting,
I think. I agree. And you know, the more I think about it, I'm simply agnostic to this idea. But
taking into consideration that there are credible reports of people achieving
reincarnation. I mean, you can judge the credibility yourself. But you know,
I consider them credible, at least, then there is there is some there is some
there is some evidence that a measure of substrate independence is possible. So but like I said,
you may not be able to upload yourself exactly as you are into the computer. But that really
depends on what your definition of what you are. If you if you say like, well, I'm the causal
structure, the water, then that thing might be computationally reducible. And you might be able
to just simply, you know, upload yourself to any substrate that supports that supports evolution
of causal structure. But your specific life experience, specific specificity of what it means
to be you, that seems to be that like, you know, like, at least from this perspective, that might be
always private to you. That like, if you imagine you merged with another being like Project 2501
situation and goes in the shell, then you don't experience that the Project 2501 wouldn't
experience you as you, he would just experience you and the Project 2501 as a one system.
Right. So the smaller system has always been only only you and that experience will always be
private, which is kind of funny because it also says that, you know, the God isn't really watching
you that carefully because it can't. Your faults are private and your real your your there's
something private to your to your existence that cannot be known. Yeah, from that perspective.
Yeah, I mean, it makes sense to me. I mean, you know, I like to make a lot of analogies to like
how, you know, what happens in computers, because those are some kind of really complex systems
that we understand really well. But, you know, if you imagine you're playing some video game,
there's like a boundary between, you know, what, what, you know, you'll experience the game and
the code that's kind of underlying that. And there's an interface like, you know, between you and
the reality of the game. And because of that interface and the way it works, you're limited
in like what can ever be observed or measured, like, you know, there's certain things through
the interface of the game, you never be able to measure. And I think it's probably similar, you
know, maybe, you know, our interface to reality or whatever things we can't actually measure due
to that, basically. But I don't know, I don't know. I honestly think that the because the main
problem here, right, like this is where I have hoped that we actually can understand fully the
nature of reality is that the things you can measure depend on your generative model.
In a sense that the first of all, there's a okay, there's putting aside the fact that we need to
develop technology to be able to measure something. First, we need to know what to measure. So as we
develop more understanding, more integrated understanding of the of the world, we're figuring
out how to extract more information out of existing data. Right, you can look at a picture of
the universe. And as we progress in time, you know, we measure more and more complex aspect
of the universe from effectively the same kind of picture, the same kind of, I mean, you know,
our technology to take pictures improved, I mean, what the picture literally going up and looking
at the stars, as our models improve, our ability to measure improves. So it's a kind of a code
dependent relationship. So, and there seems to be no bound on our ability to
increase the complexity of our generative model, so we can approximate the outside world more and
more accurately or have better and better models of it. And then we'll figure out new things to
measure. And then we'll just always keep going on. Right. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. Yeah.
Okay, cool. You know, actually, so there was one more part of the book I actually wanted to
get through. I think we'll at least try to get through a little bit of chapter eight, which is
about starting to get into kind of the quantum side of things. And like how, yeah, how does
quantum mechanics actually affect the behavior of electrons and metals and then affect things we
can't measure, right? Like, you know, conductivity. I mean, it doesn't actually, we don't cover that
till until pretty later in terms of like the measurable stuff. But the kind of beginning of
this is dealing with the idea of a periodic potential. So because like we have a crystal
lattice where you have atoms in this array in three dimensions, where from whatever atom you're
looking at, the lattice looks the same, well, each of those atoms also is like has its own little
potential energy. Like if you imagine that each of those atoms is a little planet, and you're like,
and you're the moon, right, you could be sitting there and orbiting one of those planets, or you
could be kind of moving in between them and kind of slingshotting around a bunch of those little
planets. But the important thing is that the potential energy or the force that you'll see
when you're moving along is periodic. And that if you take a step in one direction,
that's the right length, and the right length being one of the lattice vectors,
then you'll see exactly the same force as you did before. And so that's like what this equation
8.1 is saying. If you go to your page 132 in the Ashcroft Merman, 8.1 says you have little r plus
big r, lowercase r plus capital r, u of r of little r plus big r is equal to u of little r.
And so big r there is the step that you take. And big r has to be a linear combination of
the lattice vectors. And if you take a step of that kind, you'll end up at a point that looks
exactly the same as where you were before. And by looks the same, that means that you'll experience
exactly the same force as where you were before. So you could think of it almost as if you're in
this weird like house of mirrors, I guess, where when you walk far enough in any direction, you
come back to kind of where you started, that's that's how it would feel to be a crystal, I mean
to be an electron in a crystal. It makes me think of like jump gates in space, you know, like your
spaceship in space, and there are these jump gates that if you if you get into one and parachutes
you into it, it propels you exactly where you need to go to get exactly the same boost on the other
end. Jump gates? Yeah, I'm not actually familiar with that. What was that? I was like in sci-fi,
you often have the situation where a spaceship just goes into some structure that accelerates it
to some high speeds. So this is, so it's a point of, you know, some kind of high potential that
gives you velocity. So you jump it, you're jumping between these places that give you
the potential boost to travel between them. So for example, Stargate is an example of that,
and the idea is that you go through this portal that drops you into a stable wormhole that
brings you to a predictable place. Also the Expanse, I think it was like the later seasons,
they also had Stargates. Oh, I'm actually watching the Expanse now. I'm like a season four, I think.
Yeah, it's a good show. Yeah, it is great. Well, because I remember they, yeah, they discover
like this big kind of portal, but it's like a portal to many different worlds or galaxies or
whatever, wherever they go. Yeah, they're in a universe that's like a little bit different than
Stargate, but I think it's like the same general concept. So it's kind of like Stargate, you walk
into that, and on the other end, there's another Stargate that just propels you forward, right?
That's what effectively this model looks like. Yeah, okay, yeah. So I mean, if you ever played the
video game portal, right, and you put a blue portal on one wall, and then you put an orange
portal on another wall, and then you could just kind of walk between, you could walk through
the blue portal and go back through the orange one, you could keep walking the same direction,
and just keep seeing what you saw before, that's what it would be like to be an electron in a crystal.
Because of this periodic potential, you keep going and you keep seeing the same thing, basically.
So yeah, it's pretty fun to think about that on this microscopic level, it is a pretty strange
world, right, where you have this like infinite, I mean, it's not actually infinite, right, but it
would seem infinite to the electron because the crystal is really large on that length scale, but yeah.
But so the electron is just moving in these periodic potentials. So from its perspective,
effectively, kind of like nothing changes, like, or it's sort of gets accelerated from one part
to the other, where it gets the same kind of acceleration. So it would be like experiencing,
you know, like I'm thinking of like a pebble rolling in a gravitational well, just experiencing
the sort of sinusoidal acceleration. Yeah, I mean, so that's basically right. I mean,
of course, like that would be like the classical way of thinking about it, whereas in reality,
we have to like say, okay, what's going to be the wave function of the particle in this
periodic potential? That's basically right, that it just keeps going through. Now, the thing is
that while the landscape is the same, as when it goes through, when it goes enough distance to
kind of come back to the same place, the landscape is the same, but it's not exactly the same.
Where it is in that landscape, you kind of change. So in other words, you're walking in this
periodic room, but like maybe you're kind of walking on the diagonal. And so each time you
cross through the wall, you end up starting at like a place a little bit different. And so that's
kind of what it would be like for the electron. And so eventually, if it keeps going, it might
actually scatter, meaning it might actually hit, you know, a nucleus or something like that. And
so that's when things kind of, when at least its motion will change is that it'll, you know,
eventually scatter off of something. Well, I just said like this trippy thought that this is what
moving in space must actually be like at the fundamental level that, you know, I'm copying myself
from one portion of the hypergraph to another in the same way. This is sort of like the wave
function of an electron localizes it in one space or another when in reality it's not actually a
pebble moving some fields. It's just like, it's sort of manifesting itself in the space
given by the probabilities of the defined by the potentials. Right. I see. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
that's interesting. Right. Like, you know, am I the same person as I was, you know, a few seconds
ago, or if, you know, if I'm moving, you know, things like that, because we could think of all
these particles that are moving as just ripples and some kind of field, I guess. Well, so this
actually relates, I guess, to kind of where it's going, because instead of just thinking of this
as an electron being a little ball that's shooting around through this house of mirrors,
as I call it, or through the portal video game, it's actually the electron is a wave, right.
And so we think of the electron itself as being a function. So now we have two functions, right.
There's the potential energy function, which they're calling you capital U for the potential
energy function. And then there's the wave function of the electron. So you can think of the potential
energy function as like a rolling hill. I can imagine you're sledding, you know, on some, you
know, sledding in the snow, and the bumps kind of go up and down and up and down in all directions.
There's kind of different bumps. And that's the potential energy function. And that's the thing
that's periodic, right. So if you sled far enough, you'll come back to a place that looks exactly
like where you started. But now, instead of just being on my own on a little sled at one point
in space, I'm actually kind of this amorphous blob that's sledding on the hill. So I'm not just in
one place, I'm kind of spread out in some area, basically. And that's really what the electron
is like. It's kind of this amorphous blob that's sledding through the crystal in the places where,
you know, when it's going down a hill, it gets faster. And when it's going up a hill, it gets
slower. But it's not just going down a hill or going up a hill at any one time, because it's
in different places. And one part of the electron cloud could be going uphill and one part could
be going downhill, although it does kind of have a well-defined velocity, which is interesting.
You could think of that electron, which is this cloud spread out in the atom, as having a velocity
and going in some direction, basically. And so how the thing is actually modeled physically is,
you know, of course, using Schrodinger's equation, which is this 8.2 in the book on page 133.
And so that says on the left hand side, well, there's kind of three parts of it, because h psi
equals something which is equal to e psi. But you should ignore the h psi for a second. And in the
middle, we have grad squared plus u. I'll ignore the pre-factors. You have grad squared plus u,
all multiplied by psi is equal to e psi. So that's like a partial differential equation,
right? And the grad squared is kind of measuring the curvature. And so that's like,
at any point in the electron cloud, is that like kind of more dense than its surroundings or less
dense than its surroundings? So in other words, if the electron is really this cloud of kind of
density and space, and if one point in that cloud is dense compared to its surroundings,
then the grad squared of psi will be negative there. And if that point in the cloud is less
dense compared to its surroundings, then the grad squared will be positive there, okay? So that's
called the curvature. And so you do, and then there's just u, and that's the capital u is the
potential. So you multiply that by psi. And then all of that has to be equal to some number e times
psi, and e is the energy. So that's like, that's the Schrodinger equation, right? And that's what
actually governs like what the shape of that cloud basically looks like. And then the interesting
thing, the thing I wanted to get to is what's called Bloch's theorem. And what Bloch's theorem says
is that not only is the landscape the snow that you're sledding on periodic, but also the cloud
that's sledding on the electron cloud is also periodic. And so it, the electron itself is kind
of stretches out in all directions actually, kind of infinitely. And if you were to take a step in
one direction of size big R, where big R is some lattice vector, then the electron cloud would
look exactly the same there as in your original point kind of, except modulated. This is actually
important, not exactly the same. It's periodic and then modulated by a complex exponential e to the
ikr. So there's like kind of an additional ripple on top of that periodicity, I guess. Yeah.
Wow, that's a great explanation. Max, you should really start as cool, honestly.
Forget this engineering career. You should be a professor.
Well, yeah, maybe that's in the card someday. I enjoy going through these because it helps me
understand it. I actually pay a lot more attention when I'm trying to digest it in order to kind of
explain it than when I'm just reading it myself. But yeah, that was kind of block's theorem.
Right, was that the electron cloud is periodic and it has the same periodicity as the potential
with this added ripple on top of it, basically. So this added ripple on top, like in some sense,
so because the electron is moving in the potential, it sort of takes the shape of the
potential. But this added ripple also says that it has some characteristic of its own, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I think that's a good way to think about it. Yep.
So, well, it even actually, both parts have some kind of, well, let's see. Right, I guess, yeah,
both parts, both the thing, the part of it that's, let's call it the lattice periodic part, and then
the ripple part, I guess. So like, both of those parts together have to satisfy the Schrodinger
equation as a whole. So when you multiply those two things together, that object is called the
wave function, and that's the thing that has to satisfy the Schrodinger equation. But the ripple
doesn't really have any particular periodicity. It could have, I mean, it kind of does because
it depends on the whole bulk crystal, which is huge. But the lattice periodic part depends a lot
on the microscopic structure of the crystal. So you have these two things that get multiplied
together, one that depends on the size of the whole bulk crystal, and one that just depends
on the size of the local cell in the crystal, basically. So what I'm trying to say is, if you
think about the, you know, electron as a kind of like a vortex in some kind of graph, right, like
Wolfram you're thinking, then this equation seems to say that basically you can separate the wave
function of an electron moving through that kind of field as the part that is reflective of the
vessel it's contained in, and the part that's somewhat intrinsic to it.
Right. Yeah, that's a good question. I honestly, like, yeah, I'm not totally sure if like,
if like what part should be thought of as like intrinsic versus reflect. I guess I think that's
kind of right in that the... Well, the thing about this way, like if an electron is moving in a
different potential, then that part of, there will be a part of it that will be reflective of the
potential. It will diffuse in the potential, in the way that the potential allows it to diffuse.
Does the space for the fractal to unpack, so to speak, and take some space?
But there is also the thing that makes the fractal fractal, that makes it an actual electron.
Right. Yeah, I guess that's right. Yeah, because when you go to a different crystal
and a different potential, basically the part of the wave function that's the lattice periodic part
will change a lot, whereas you'll always have that complex exponential function multiplying it,
which is kind of, yeah, I guess you're right, that's kind of characteristic of the fact that it's an
electron. And you know, the fact that the complex exponential is a rotation in the complex plane,
that also seems to be like, like that's a, that's a, to me, that always felt like that's a computation
in a different, in a different dimension, so to speak, right, or orthogonal to whatever it is.
So it's a moving for space, unpacking into space, that's one, one dimension of computation, but
like, you know, at some angle to that, there's the actual computation, the, the, the, the actual
vortex that, that makes the electron, electron. Yeah. Yeah. So that's actually super important,
the fact that, right, right, the fact that the complex exponential can be thought of as a rotation
in the complex plane, because the next thing on this, like, page 134 is the proof of Bloch's
theorem, and it uses that, the fact that the complex exponential is a rotation in the complex plane,
because if you imagine a complex exponential function, like e to the i kx, where x is, you know,
or k is just some number, and x is like the x-axis, then what does that look like as we travel along
the x-axis? Well, e to the i kx kind of looks like a spiral that's going counterclockwise around
the x-axis. If, if instead of like the y and z-axis, we had like the imaginary part of e to the i kx,
the real part of e to the i kx and the imaginary part, like we're just plotting the real part and
the imaginary part, and, and now as we go along the x-axis, we see this spiral that goes in a,
in a counterclockwise direction, and the interesting thing about that spiral is that if you translate
it along x, if I say x, I'm going to replace x with x plus one and just slide the whole spiral
around along on the x-axis, well, if I then rotate the spiral, then I can get it to coincide with
what it looked like originally. So you can always kind of, you can undo a translation of a spiral
by a rotation, okay? And so that, or another way of saying it, that is that complex exponentials are
these, or these spirals we were talking about are eigenfunctions of the translation operator,
because what an eigenfunction is, it's something that when you apply an operator,
you get back the same function, but multiplied by some constant. And so in other words, these
complex exponentials, they're eigenfunctions of the translation, because when you translate them,
you get back the same thing that's multiplied by a constant, or in other words, rotated in the
complex plane. Yeah. But you know, one thing about the complex plane as a construction that
always struck me, the thing that was kind of like an enlightening moment, is that when I started
thinking about this, is that it's a construction that allows you to get out of the real plane into
some other space. So you say like, well, I would like to describe part of my process in a space
that is nowhere incidental on the real space. So it's kind of like an effect in this, you know,
orthogonal, orthogonal to reality, so to speak. Then all you have to do is to do this rotation,
and suddenly you have a lot of space to do something else. Right. Yeah, it is interesting,
in a lot of times. That is preserved by translations in the real space, as you just said.
Right? Right. So the essence of that thing, that I suddenly have a process, kind of like
that can be going on, there could be stuff happening there, and I can describe it in this
other space, and I can translate my object in the real space, and that thing is going to be unaffected.
The reference frame changes. So I may need to do a little bit of jiggling to really see
that this is the same thing, but it is the same thing. Yeah. Yeah, it really is very, you know,
it really is really, really strange. I mean, because like, yeah, a lot of times when we're
given some physical system that has a very nicely kind of prescribed set of coordinates,
like a bunch of masses on springs or whatever, or voltages, and then it kind of has these natural
coordinates of, you know, X, Y, and Z, or the voltages on different conductors, then like the
first thing we'll do in physics is we'll introduce all these other coordinates by going to a complex
space, and so now all of a sudden we have twice the number of numbers, right, because for every X
we now have an imaginary part, and those imaginary parts are not real, right, like they're both in
the mathematical in the actual sense, like they don't exist anywhere in nature that we know about,
but they just make it easier to kind of predict what's going to happen. And so instead of having
a sinusoid, you have this spiral, which to me has always been very strange that, you know,
that's how kind of how we end up doing things. Think about it this way. If I give you a piece of
memory, right, a computer memory, I'm just going to give you a memory dump. It absolutely makes
no sense whatsoever to you unless, you know, what is the operating system that this, say, program
is running on? What are the rules? What's the virtual architecture? So where is this architecture
that allows you to execute that program? Well, it's not in the hardware. It's not in the program
itself. Where is it? Well, you can't find it anywhere. It's a causal structure that exists
in a space that's orthogonal to reality. That's the platonic realm, effectively. So in some sense,
this construct, to me, this construction is to basically say like, well, I need this other space,
this platonic space, to describe part of the process, because it's nowhere, no, it's part of
a process that's not actually dependent on the physical part of the system. It's something else.
So complex plane is a construction that gives you ability to go there. And this is the nice thing
that all you have to do is to multiply by i, and suddenly you're out of whatever real space you've
defined for yourself. Right. Yeah, I see. I kind of see that way of looking at it. You know what I
always wanted to do is say, all right, well, if you're going to give me an equation, a differential
equation, and treat x as a complex variable, then why don't I just turn that into two equations in
real variables, right? Because it must be somewhere that other variable, right? So we can just treat
it as a real difference. And you can think of all of the complex analysis in this way that whenever
you see an i, you just replace it by a matrix, like a two by, a little two by two matrix. And then
when you have a matrix of complex numbers, you can just replace that by a matrix that's twice as
large and you get back to real numbers. But I think your way of looking at it is also interesting,
maybe better, that instead of trying to look for those complex numbers somewhere in reality,
you just think of it as like, there's like another way of thinking of things that isn't,
like, actually in, you know, better than reality anywhere, you know, either hardware or software,
that's just kind of this separate world, I guess. Sorting algorithm is an ideal that
or platonic form that exists independent of any kind of realization. It will always exist,
it always has existed, it could not exist, it's just there, right? It wasn't invented, it's just
a thing. So that's how I think about it, like from this angle, from my computer science background,
like, and the reason I think about it is just because once I started thinking about it this way,
it all started to make sense instead of just memorizing rules and, you know, just drilling
it into my head until I can compute with it. It's like, oh, I get it. Right, yeah, yeah, makes sense,
yeah. All right, well, so I'm just gonna kind of finish the like, I guess, I don't know what to
call it, lecture portion with this kind of final thought on on Bloch's theorem, which is basically
a proof of Bloch's theorem. And, and Bloch's theorem was the thing that said that when you had
the periodic potential or the periodic landscape that you're sweating on, then the wave function
or the electron cloud is also periodic with the same periodicity in all directions. And, and the
proof this, I really like this first proof, I give two, but I'm not going to go into the second one,
but the first one I think is pretty, pretty nice and elegant. And what it says is that, well, first
of all, we were going to talk about this translation operator. And what it does, it just takes a
function and moves it kind of in like the x, y, and z directions. So the translation operator,
it also has like another kind of argument there that's hidden, which is what vector you're going
to translate the function by, but its input is really the function. And then it's kind of,
other side argument is the translation vector. And then its output is the translated function,
which is just the function. But if you, if now if you input some point in space, you would get
the output of the original function at a different point in space, you know, translated.
And so the, the important thing here is that when you take the, when you take Schrodinger's
equation, and you say, let's say I had a solution to Schrodinger's equation, I had a solution to
this partial differential equation that includes kind of the curvature of the function and the
potential energy. And let's say I translated that solution. Let's see. So, or actually,
sorry, maybe that's not the right way to say it. If you apply the translation operator,
I guess, on both sides of the equation, then what happens is you see that basically the,
the translation operator kind of commutes with the Hamiltonian in that you can,
you can translate this function psi either before you apply this differential operator,
which is the curvature plus the potential, or you could first apply that operator and then
translate the function and you get out the same thing. And that kind of is something you could
see if you, if you just write out Schrodinger's equation and you apply this translation operator.
And then what happens in, is something we know kind of from quantum mechanics is whenever two
operators commute, they share a basis of, of eigenfunctions. An eigenfunction is,
is just something that when I apply an operator to it, if, if, if psi is an eigenfunction of h,
then when I apply h to psi, I get back psi multiplied by some constant. So we, we now know
that because the Hamiltonian commutes with the translation operator, that the eigenfunctions
of the Hamiltonian and the translation operator are the same. But we also know what the eigenfunctions
of the translation operator are, because we know that when we like translate these, these complex
exponentials, or, or periodic functions, right, when we, when we, or actually you're right,
when we take any like periodic function multiplied by a complex exponential, we get back the same
periodic function multiplied by some constant, right, because whenever you translate that complex
exponential, you just extract as kind of a scalar multiple. And so the idea here is that
those eigenfunctions are the same. And so now we know what the eigenfunctions of the Hamiltonian
are. They have to be these, these functions that when we translate them by lattice vectors,
we get back the same thing multiplied by some, by some complex number. And so those end up being
these kind of block form functions where you have a complex exponential multiplied by a periodic
function. So that might have not been the best explanation, but that's, that's kind of the idea
is that using the fact that the translation operator commutes with a Hamiltonian, and the
Hamiltonian itself is periodic, you can figure out what, you know, what the properties of the
eigenfunctions are of the Hamiltonian. And those, those eigenfunctions of the Hamiltonian are going
to be super important because those are the energy levels of the, of the electrons in the crystal kind
of. Yeah. So yeah, I don't know if that's, that's something that, that, that proof relies a lot on
like kind of going through the standard quantum curriculum where you talk a lot about commuting
operators and their shared eigenfunctions. So maybe, you know, maybe not the most intuitive thing, but
at least in terms of quantum, it's kind of a nice connection, I think.
Nice. That's, that's a little bit over my head. I'm not that familiar with the
standard quantum curriculum, or at least it's been like 10 years since I, since I had it. So
yeah, but, but, but, but I get the gist, like, especially this, this commuting part, that argument
is, you, you, you laid it out very clearly. That totally makes sense. Yeah. Yeah. And there's something
in there that's still kind of mysterious, I think, which is like, why is it that operators that commute
have like shared eigenfunctions? Honestly, yeah, I don't have a great intuitive kind of grasp of
that. It's just something that, like, just one of these mathematical facts, I guess, but
yeah, we'd love to understand it better, honestly, but if it's connected to all these deep things
in physics, like Neuter's theorem, where all like symmetries are connected with conserved
quantities and stuff like that. Definitely. Because the fact that they commute, that's a kind of a
symmetry, right? Right. Well, yeah, it's interesting, because that's like kind of a formal symmetry,
like in the, in the world of symbols, but then it actually ends up being related to, like, a
physical symmetry, kind of, in actual, like, in transforming space, which is kind of interesting
thing about, yeah. I wonder if all of this is going, and maybe it says this in the text somewhere,
but does crystal structure, does knowing the crystal structure let you predict conductivity,
kind of like, you know, ceramics and superconductors, and I don't know if there is, if it helps you
predict that sort of thing, so you can design better materials? Yeah, you know, definitely.
That's like one of the most important, like, properties, I would say, you know, that this kind
of, that this theory of, like, solid state physics can predict is the conductivity of,
of materials, of both, like, metals and semiconductors. And even more importantly,
like, how that conductivity depends on things you do to the material, like, for example, if you
change the temperature, the conductivity could change a lot, like, in a semiconductor, like,
you can go from being an insulator to being a conductor, basically, like, something that doesn't
conduct, that's something that does. So, yeah, that's like one of the key things to, to look at
here is, like, conductivity and properties like that. But, yeah, and actually, so it's kind of
relates to what they get into a little bit later in here is, like, band structure, and that basically
just has to do with, like, what, what kind of states an electron can be in, in a metal, like,
because there, there, there end up being, like, because of quantum mechanics in these, like,
this weird, you know, world of the electron cloud that has to be periodic, there, there are kind of,
like, speed limits. It's almost like, there's certain, there are certain speeds that it's allowed
to go, and other speeds that it's just not allowed to go. And so normally, you think of a speed limit
by being, you can't go over 60 miles an hour here, but in the world of electrons and crystals,
they're more like weird speed limits where it's like, you're not allowed to go between 60 and 80
miles an hour, but you're allowed to go lower than 60, and you're allowed to go higher than 80,
right? So that'll be, like, a pretty weird speed limit. But that's kind of, that's like how it is
in a semiconductor. And that's, like, kind of, kind of like a band gap, where there's, like, gaps in
the energy that aren't, that, you know, electrons aren't allowed to exist at that energy, and they
can exist kind of above and below. And that's, like, the key to, like, seeing, like, why basically
something can, why something can be a semiconductor that can, like, conduct at one temperature and
not at another, that if, if basically, if all of the state, like, you think of it as, like, a highway,
where, like, when there's a bunch of cars on the highway, kind of, all the states are filled,
and maybe there's, like, a left lane where you're allowed to go fast, and there's, like, a right
lane where you can't go fast or something. And what it basically depends on is, like, whether,
if there is an open lane where there's electron can go there, then you can conduct. And if all the
lanes are full, then you can't, basically. And there, and because of these, like, weird speed
limits where there's, there's gaps in the, you know, speeds you can travel, it can be really hard to,
like, accelerate up to, you know, you end up in a situation where you want to accelerate the
electron to a higher speed, but there's no speed available there because there's a gap in the
band structure. So that's kind of how these semiconductors work, I guess. Is, is that where
doping comes in? Or is that something different? Like, does doping give you, does it help cover
some of the band? Yeah, that's exactly, that's exactly what it does, is it makes new lanes in
the gap, you know, it makes new energy levels in the gap between the two bands. So that'll be,
like, saying, like, okay, we had this speed limit where you weren't allowed to go between 88 or between
60 and 80, but now we're going to add a new kind of little speed that you can go in, in between
there somewhere. I mean, this is, it's definitely an oversimplification, like, there's a lot of
complexity, but that's, I think that's, like, a reasonable way to think about it, that it adds
extra levels in the band gap, basically. Yeah.
But this is a very classical analogy. Do you think you could, you could make it quantum?
Yeah, well, so the quantum way to think about it would be if you looked at figure, like,
let's see, I think if you looked at figure, where is this?
Here's somewhere.
Well, for 8.1, not 8.1, actually.
Oh yeah, it's in the next chapter, actually. Sorry, it's in the next chapter.
Right. The weak periodic potential. I guess, like, figure 9.1 kind of, right? So,
yeah, can you guys see figure 9.1, where you have these kind of two, like,
paraboloids that intersect each other? Yes. Okay. So, what that picture is kind of about is that,
well, let's see. So, I guess, you can think of k, the x-axis in this figure, k, you can think of
that as, like, momentum, right? And you can think of the y-axis as the energy. And so, we know that,
like, the energy, kinetic energy is proportional to the square of momentum, or to the square of speed,
right? E equals one-half mv squared. So, I mean, I know that still seems kind of
classical. But that's also true for, you know, Schrodinger's equation. You have a factor of p
squared, where p is that differential operator derivative with respect to x. And this figure
is actually, you're supposed to think about it in terms of quantum states. So, instead of, like,
thinking about a point, you know, a ball that's, like, moving in some direction with a certain
velocity, when I say it has a momentum of k, you should really think of, like, that as being the
wave vector, or, like, the frequency of the wave. So, if it has a higher momentum, that means it's
a higher frequency, or a shorter wavelength, basically. And lower momentum, that means a longer
wavelength. But you could also think of it as being a ball moving some direction in space,
or being an electron, like, you know, as a point, kind of moving some direction in space.
And so, what that paraboloid is, is that's that, like, energy equals one-half mb squared, right?
The energy proportional to the square of momentum. If you look at the paraboloid that kind of,
it's where its bottom is, where the y-axis kind of starts out of. But then something,
like, kind of strange happens, that instead of just the energy increasing as you increase k,
there's, like, this other paraboloid that starts a little bit over to the right.
And the reason that basically happens, well, you can kind of think about it in terms of,
like, one way to think about it is in terms of aliasing, actually, which is something in,
like, signal processing. And what it has to do with this is that-
Yeah, I was just thinking about it.
Yeah, yeah. So, it really does have to do with aliasing. So, if I have a, well, think about
like this, like, let's say, if you've ever seen a video of somebody recording a helicopter, like,
on a video, sometimes it'll look like the rotor is spinning, like, really slowly, actually.
So, or similarly, if you see a recording from a car and you see the hubcap on the car, it looks
like it's rotating slowly, or sometimes even rotating backwards. And why does that happen?
Well, it can happen, for example, if the rate that the rotor is rotating at
is synchronized to the shutter speed of the camera, right? Because if you take a picture,
every time the rotor has made a full rotation, you'll see it in the same place and it'll just
look like it's sitting still. Or if you take a picture just a little bit slower than that,
then every time you take a picture, the rotor will move a little bit farther, and so you'll see it,
like, rotating really slowly around, kind of. And the point is that when you take a wave,
and then you sample it at discrete points in time, if you sample too slowly, you'll basically see,
like, a different wave. You'll still see a wave, but it'll just be a wave at a different frequency.
And so, that's, like, the idea of aliasing is that when you sub-sample, or when you sample a
wave at a lower frequency, you'll see kind of a different wave of a lower frequency.
And when we look at a crystal, basically, you can think of, like, the electron in space as being
this really high frequency oscillation, where the wavelength is really small, but then the actual
atoms in the crystal are kind of the sites and the points in that lattice are pretty far away
from each other compared to the wavelength of the electron, at least if the electron is moving fast
enough. And so, what actually ends up being important is, like, what the electron looks like
where it's close to the atoms. And if you think of the atoms as kind of, like, measuring, or, like,
yeah, measuring what the electron looks like, if the frequency or the wavelength of that electron,
if the wavelength is really small, as far as the atoms are concerned, they'll see it as being just
at a lower frequency or being at a higher wavelength. And so, that's really what's happening here,
where when we compare these two, when we go move forward on the x-axis, when we move from left to
right, is that we're increasing the frequency or decreasing the wavelength of the electron
until it gets small enough that the wavelength starts to look longer, actually, relative to the
atoms. So, you could think of it as, like, I'm recording a helicopter at a constant shutter
speed and the speed of the rotor speeds up and speeds up. And on my camera, I see the rotor
getting faster and faster until it gets fast enough that it starts to, that it slows down. It
actually looks like it's at a lower frequency. And so, in the quantum, the way to think about this
in a quantum way is that the electron is a wave that's basically being measured by all the atoms,
or it's kind of, its energy depends on what it looks like relative to all the atoms. And so,
where that kind of speed limit comes from is that when you increase the energy of the electron enough,
it, like, crosses over into that, like, aliasing, basically. And so, now, it, you know, it, well,
its energy is going to end up decreasing again. That's definitely losing a lot in kind of the,
it's losing a lot, but I think that's at least a start towards understanding it. And partly,
because I don't understand it myself very well, but because I need to read this chapter in more
detail of it, yeah. Right now, that totally makes sense. So, essentially, we had this, like,
semiconductor, and you have to say, you could use, I suppose, temperature to change the,
to translate the band of energy one way or another, right? And effectively, it's kind of like alignment
of reference frames, that electron can, you just have to, you just have to make it possible for
electron to sort of, you know, manifest in the material, so to speak, from the, from the electron
field. Right. Yeah, or you could imagine as, like, what, like, what you would do if you were
trying to accelerate the electrons as you would, you would apply an electric field, kind of, and
so that would be, like, trying to get the electrons to move over to the, to the right in this, in this
picture. But I'm trying to, specifically, not to think in classical terms, just try to get used
to thinking in terms of waves. So, it's more like, I want the information transfer to some,
to happen, but to do that, I have to align my sampling frequency, my reference frame,
in order to let the, to be able to observe the thing it wants, so the information starts flowing.
Right. Yeah. Yeah, that was a very good description. And as you were saying about
moving these paraboloids, I was like, exactly, that feels like, yeah, that's, that's kind of,
like, aliasing. And it's interesting that in some videos, you know, sometimes you have these funny
videos of, like, a bird in front of, like, some ring camera or something, and it looks like it's
just hovering in the air. The wings are perfectly synchronized with the shutter, so it looks as
they're not moving. That's what there is. Yeah. Yeah, that's exactly it. And that's why they,
they have, well, so to go back to this thing we were talking about, called the unit cell, or the,
well, actually, in particular, the Wigner-Seitz unit cell, there's this, like, really important,
this, like, maybe, like, one of the most important concepts in solid state physics is what's called
the Brillouin zone, or the first Brillouin zone, it was, like, kind of a special case of it, named
out this guy, Leon Brillouin, who actually also made some important contributions to the information
theory. And as it's just a plug, Brillouin, he has this good book called Science and Information
Theory. But the, the idea of the Brillouin zone is really all about that aliasing, that, well,
first of all, we're in three dimensions here. So the frequency, or the spatial frequency,
which is how many ripples the wave has when you take a step in some direction, is not just a
number, but it's a vector, right? Because if I take a step in one direction, there might be a lot
of ripples. But if I take a step in another direction, there might be no ripples, right? Like,
if you just think of, like, waves on the beach, if I'm going perpendicular to the beach, to the
beach head, I see a bunch of ripples. Whereas if I'm walking, like, parallel to the beach head,
I won't cross any ripples, right? So that's why it's called a wave vector, which is both the
frequency and the direction which the waves are propagating, getting in. And so we're in this
three-dimensional space of all the possible wave vectors, right? That's what's called reciprocal
space. A point in that space represents a wave that is, that has a particular frequency,
and is traveling in a particular dimension, direction. And now, when I go out far enough
to farther and farther frequency waves, eventually I get a wave that,
from the crystal's perspective, looks the same because of aliasing. And so what they do is
they basically say, well, it's periodic. You're not allowed to, like, really cross out of that
zone. You kind of come back through the other side of it. And that zone is called the Brillouin zone,
or the first Brillouin zone, in what they call cave space, sort of space of all wave vectors.
And that's like, it's probably the most, like, fundamental thing that characterizes a crystal,
is what it's like Brillouin zone looks like, or, you know, which describes the geometry of the
lattice, basically, in terms of the waves. So yeah, that's how I think you can kind of think about
the, this, like, aliasing connection in a crystal and what the Brillouin zone is.
Right. That's really interesting.
Yeah. Sorry. Go ahead.
Yeah, actually, yeah, I'm not sure, but I think, like, the picture on the cover of the book,
it's probably either, like, a Fermi surface or a Brillouin zone. I'm not actually sure. It's
probably one or the other, but I don't really know, honestly. But yeah.
But yeah, go ahead, Christophe, are you going to say something?
I don't know that your exposition just still made me think about this,
that this fact that you always have this sort of situation of being,
you know, unlimited observer, observing some phenomenon that has more degrees of freedom
than you have. So in this case, the fact that you just simply have to conflate
information you get because of this aliasing, because of these very, very, very high frequency
waves that, you know, you just can't observe the fact that they're so high frequency,
do you just have to conflate it with whatever you can measure?
Right. Yeah. Yeah, and actually, there's something they call, like, a crystal momentum,
which is like, so the electron, of course, has some, like, physical momentum, right,
which is either, you could think of it as, like, h times k, its wave vector,
or as, like, m times v, its mass times velocity, but it also has a crystal momentum,
which is that momentum basically aliased to the crystal. And so, yeah, it really is like that,
like, that the world it's living in, which is, like, discreet, is basically determining, you know,
to what, like, resolution you can view its properties, kind of.
Yeah. Yeah. And the crystal momentum ends up being, like, the kind of conserved quantity
in, within the crystal. So it's almost like this, it's almost like a bad simulation of
reality. How do you think of, like, what's going on in the crystal is, like, this,
this kind of flawed simulation, where it can't really understand momentum, like, above a certain
point. And so it just aliases them back to below that kind of, you know.
Well, you know, there's this, one of the seven hermetic principles from hermetic philosophy,
it's basically says, as above so below, so below as above, and turns McKenna very nicely restated
that nature is self-similar across scale. So in some sense, the space within a crystal that
permits the electron field to invade that structure, right, will reflect the structure
of the field up to whatever can be reflected in the structure, right? Like, it's kind of,
like, almost logical that you can capture whatever you can capture. And as long as soon as, as soon
as the conditions for the flow of the electron field into the into the crystal are satisfied,
then it will just naturally tend to expand into wherever it can it can go.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, no, it definitely, yeah, definitely, I think that's a good way of thinking
about it. It's, it's really, it's almost like a, it's almost like a different universe when you're,
when you're inside of a crystal and you're the size of the electron and the crystal is,
for your purposes, it's basically infinitely large. And it has its own kind of laws of physics,
like that ends up being, I think, the right way to think about it. And of course, you can think
of it everything in terms of our ordinary laws of physics, right? And you can just apply Schrodinger's
equation and everything. But the way to, you know, the way that the theory really develops in that
we predict all these properties is like thinking of its own little universe that has its own laws
kind of based on this, you know, based on this structure where space is kind of discretized
or at least like periodic in a way. Yeah. And you know, to go back to one of our previous
conversations when they said about how Maxwell used to think about the world and he had this,
he had this model of the, of the world and the model of what the function of a scientist is,
is to basically use the intuition from the physical, from the mechanical, from the familiar,
from the scale that we operate on to construct a model of what's happening on other scales by,
and by kind of analogizing. And I think this is what we've been doing in the book so far.
A lot of this stuff was like, well, the electrons are kind of like gas, but not really,
but let's just apply the same mathematics and see what shakes out and we got some approximation of
what's happening in the material and so on and so forth. And at some point you're starting to relax
the assumptions of the, that are familiar, the localization in space and time and so on and so
forth. And you get this, and you get these more interesting models. But the parallel that there
was always some parallel to be made with the phenomena that are familiar to us at our scale,
because at all scales, nature, nature, nature is self-similar. It doesn't mean it's the same,
it just means that there are aspects that, you know, can be captured with at a higher level,
that it can be captured at a lower level and vice versa. And Hermetics would say something
cryptic that like, you know, by comprehending the monad, he understands the archangel that you can
infer the structure of the heavens from what's happening on earth.
Right. Yeah. And as you were saying, like about how, I think this is like a good kind of like,
yeah, theme of the book is like different ways of approximating reality by pretending it's
something that's like relatively easier for us to reason about, right? And so we start off by
imagining that it's just a bunch of balls bouncing around in this Pashinko machine or whatever.
And then you kind of expect like, yeah, as we go down to the quantum level and incorporate more,
more physics, like things are kind of getting more realistic in a way they are, like in a way
it's getting more realistic and we can get better predictions. But in another way, it's actually,
we end up like ignoring more and more things actually, like as we include more quantum physics,
we realized, oh, well, there's also all these like, not only are the electrons interacting
with each other, but they can also be entangled with each other or with the nuclear things like
that, but we're gonna, we can throw that out the window basically for various reasons. And so as
the model gets more complex, it also becomes more reductive actually, which, you know, so if we
started off with a, with a spherical cow, we ended up with, there's a guy I talked to on here who,
who said that he somehow mixed it up and said that we, that physics, we like to make things
into flat cows, which is maybe not a bad way to think. We started off with a spherical cow and
we end up with a flat cow or something that's even somehow even more reductive basically.
But it is interesting that we end up with better predictions, but there's still like extremely
like simplistic ways to look at the world because what we really get out of our, you know, theoretical
advancements is we realize there's all this complexity and all these other effects that
can happen. And then the kind of game is to figure out what, you know, we can ignore and whether we
can kind of ignore more and more different things, I think. Yeah. I guess in some sense, you can,
you can start ignoring things like entanglement and so on, because you're looking at this from a
very statistical perspective in a way that like you're, we're taking very large samples of,
you know, of the system, like in the temporal scale, compared to the interactions between
individual electrons with electrons and electrons with atoms. By the time we care about any effect
of that, there has been so many that any individual entanglements and non-New Yorker relations and
all of that just kind of like have been smoothed out until, until we find effects where we care
and we're going to have to go back and be like, okay, now we can measure, now we can, now we
actually see the difference. Yeah. Yeah, definitely. I mean, and especially because like when in terms
of the classical way of thinking, like whenever you want to incorporate some new effect, kind of
the first tool in the toolbox is to like just use some Taylor expansion to say like, well, yeah,
what's the first order dependence on this? And like, what's the second order dependence?
And so the more effects you try to include, you basically end up with some kind of crazy
Taylor expansion in a bunch of different variables, which ends up being like not a very useful model
and not very wieldy, and it doesn't really help you understand the thing intuitively too well.
But yeah, there's something I'm really curious about is, so something kind of an idea I've been
working on and thinking about a little bit is like whether we can, because we've talked about this
before actually how like maybe the like neural networks are going to be the Taylor expansion
of the 21st century in that not only we'll use them for just extrapolation, but they'll also
become kind of the basis of like the math of theoretical physical models basically of things.
And I've kind of been thinking about like, you know, is there a way to leverage like thermodynamics
to figure out what's the right function basically to fit with neural networks to get a good
understanding of materials basically. And but yeah, basically using kind of neural networks as a
on zots for thermodynamic functions, like potential thermodynamic potentials like free
energies and partition functions and things like that to model materials and semiconductors and
stuff like that. Yeah, I have a feeling that there definitely is there is a there are some
really interesting theoretical results that that that that suggests that that might be possible.
Are you familiar with the technique called Cindy sparse identification of nonlinear dynamics?
No, actually, yeah, I know I haven't heard of that. So the idea is really simple.
You know, there's a great paper about Cindy Ote and coders and just trying to reproduce the
results from right now. Actually, you take something like a high dimensional representation of a
system. So for instance, a video of a pendulum or just generated, you know, animation of a
damped pendulum. And what you want is to produce the equations of motion. So there are two things
that need to happen. One is essentially coordinate transformation that will allow you to discover
a low dimensional coordinate system that describes the motion of a pendulum, in this case, a single
variable coordinate system, right? And the nice thing is that when you're investigating, you
already know the answer. So like, you can, you know, the answers, you know, the governing equations,
you can generate the data, you can you can simulate it to your heart content, and then you
can start playing with neural networks. It's a very fun thing to play with. So you squeeze it
from auto encoder into some kind of low dimensional space. And you say like, okay, I'm going to have
this low dimensional representation. And then you can you have this dictionary of candidate
functions from which you can you can construct the governing equation. And what you're trying to do
is a is a kind of a linear regression with a lost term that encourages sparsity. So you want you
essentially trying to say to the neural network, please find me a coordinate transformation of
the system from high dimensional, from this high dimensional space of my observations of data
into something that's low dimensional. That's actually I'm able to doing this regression
technique that will give me an equation in that in the low dimensional, you know, coordinates.
That's also sparse. And it's, it's a bit fragile. But it's, it can be made to work. And people
actually apply that to reinforcement learning as well. So you have an reinforcement learning agent
that interacts with, you know, the costly simulation of some kind of physical system site,
and then you construct a Cindy model, and it doesn't have to be perfect, but you have something.
And then you learn then the reinforcement learning for a while can learn, you know,
against this reduced model, that's really cheap to compute because you have the equation. So you can
just, you can just sort of, you know, guide the guide the learning in a certain direction,
if it is not perfect. And then you do the rollout of the new neural network into the
full environment, and collect more data, and so on, and you continue. And that can actually,
that can dramatically improve sample efficiency when modeling physical systems. So, you know,
I think, I think as time goes on, we will effectively get an entire lingo of how to
essentially think about this, almost as if like, you know, how many degrees of,
I feel that it's something related to tensor decomposition, tensor network decomposition
and the area law, that, you know, for certain situations, you can sort of know that, you know,
the nonlinear correlations are not that important to the thing that you're trying to model in the
state that you're trying to model because it's kind of the ground state that you really care about.
So the area law kind of starts to apply and you only care about what's observable on the
boundary between the system and the environment. And if you, if we could figure out how to sort
of dynamically adjust the neural network somehow to figure out what is the optimal size of that
boundary, right? That's going to be the kind of vocabulary that we're going to have. You're
going to have these systems that are just basically your modeling entangled system,
that's the function of a neural network to simply model nonlinear correlations in a kind of
an entangled system. And then your, the important part is going to be the specification of the
bandwidth of the boundary between the components of the system. So you can think of the one-dimensional
Ising model as this very specific structure. And that's why that's precisely why you can
decompose it because the interactions only happen at this very well-defined boundary,
something along those lines. Interesting. Yeah. And while I like the analogy of the Ising model,
for example, because like, yeah, Ising models are like one of the kind of triumphs of
statistical physics was like deriving partition functions for Ising models and like one and two
dimensions and stuff like that. But then like that's like about as kind of far as wet because
anything that's, and that's like already a pretty incredibly simple, you know, model. But
when you go to things that are more complicated, it's just analytically pretty much impossible to
do in a closed form. And it's just kind of why I think like, you know, the behavior ultimately
can't be that complicated. It's just our way of describing it that is not a good fit. Like it's
just our, when we try to write out an equations and the closed forms that we're familiar with,
that's not a good fit. So I think ultimately a partition function won't be something you try to
derive, but something you download, you know, from Hugginface or whatever. And then off you go,
you know, modeling the thermodynamics of your system. And to do this now, we basically do all
these really expensive Monte Carlo simulations where we do, you know, millions of simulated
trajectories of a system, because we don't have a closed form for its, you know, its statistical
the functions that describe as statistics. And I just think that like, these functions can be
learned. And they're, you know, they're not like input output for like a self driving car,
but they are, they're, they're still functions that, you know, describe the statistics of these
many body systems. So, but here's what the right data is, you know, here's a kicker. There's a
paper that I think is going to be, to turn out to be a lot more important than so far it has been,
it's titled, your classifier is secretly an energy based model, and you should treat it as such.
Let me, one second. So the gist of the paper is basically that if you take a standard classifier
trained on a cross entropy loss, it's actually hiding a full generative model. So let me just
read you the abstract, this is really interesting. We propose to reinterpret a standard discriminative
classifier p of y given x as an energy based model for the joint distribution p of x and y.
In this setting, the standard class probabilities can be easily computed as well,
unnormalized values p of x and p of x given y. So basically, what it, what it, what it is saying
is that even though the partition function is generally intractable, by doing classification,
you're getting effectively a partition function for free.
Right. Interesting. Yeah, probably that's interesting. You can somehow sample p of x
or compute p of x from a classifier that is supposed to give you p of x given y or p of y
given x, I guess. It's wild. I'll just post the link to the paper, but like it's, I think it's,
and they also have a follow up work. It's called entitled oops, I took a gradient, and they show
how there was a very, there was a much better way to sample from that, that they have a very,
very nice improved sampling, sampling algorithm. So yeah, I totally agree with you that like these,
these neural networks will be these partition functions that you sort of, they will be,
they are these partition functions. A classifier is a partition function and a general model.
So you can use it, you can use it both ways. You can, you can generate from it and you can
actually use it to solve your problems. So I think, I think there's going to be a new,
new vocabulary, that's the top of that vocabulary, new kind of physics will emerge.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, definitely. And I mean, I think like one of the things that it's been kind of,
we've seen recently is like, you know, AI has done really good at these kind of like trial and error
things where it has really good guesses basically, like alpha geometry, it can guess a proof that
can then be checked by some formal proof system. And I think like these just in check tasks,
where the checking is really easy are like the key to AI, I'm not going to use the term AGI,
but things that we would all agree have surpassed like human capability, like AlphaGo and in
chess and whatever that we're like, because it can be checked, you know, it can, it can quickly
learn to play better than a human. And I think it's going to be similar with like material science
basically that will be because there's so much effort that goes into trying to like guess what
good materials will be. And then they run, you know, density functional theory, DFT or whatever.
And they say, Oh, well, it didn't didn't work out so well after all. But this seems like a
perfect application for, you know, basically learning to, you know, learning to produce
materials that have the properties you want, basically. Yeah, but you know, there's a project
that I'm thinking I've been thinking about for a while. And I don't know if I should mention it
here, because it's good. If this stuff actually works, it's going to have some funny consequences
for the world. But maybe like, you know, to help with it, like, imagine that you what you're guessing
is the is is the and nonce of the Bitcoin block. So train train train a neural network to basically
use use neural acceleration to basically break Bitcoin, and be able to get to get every single
block. There's like a billion dollars to be made right there. Right. I see. Yeah, that's although
you made Bitcoin as a result. Yeah, yeah, I looked into some papers at one point, not not like
terribly similar, but I guess a little bit related and like trying to attack encryption
with neural networks was like a, like people tried training a neural network to predict
like PRNGs basically, like an attack on PRNGs by trying to predict their outputs from a portion
of their outputs. I don't think it did terribly well. But yeah, I mean, I think that the function
is just too like, you know, discontinuous. Or I mean, maybe not. Like, it's just too complex to
describe the function in the parameterization of the neural network, basically, like you who need
to, you would need so many, like the complexity is probably worse than other like known attacks
that are already that people already know how to do will be my guess. But I don't know, maybe
there's like, to me will be surprising if there turned out to be some structure that it could
understand. But, you know, maybe there is, I don't know, but yeah, my guess is that hash functions
are more primitive. So, so there is a more possibility for that. And also the, you know,
you could do the initial what you could try is do they have a neural network to have the initial
gas, and then just simply iterate from there. Just assume that it's that the neural network
might be guessing somewhere in the vicinity, which is a little bit different from, which is,
I think it's a smaller space than encryption, because there's this non, well, it's a big number.
I think it's a, it's more constrained than the general encryption problem.
I see. Yeah. Yeah, I mean, you know, it will be, I mean, yeah, if it worked, like it would prove,
you know, it would probably be a breakthrough in, in just computer science in general, you know,
if you could do something with better complexity with somewhere in the algorithm. I think what
it will probably be really good at is finding like implementation errors, right? Because a lot of
these like, you know, how do you know if there's an implementation error in your crypto, you know,
not until something goes wrong, but because people can't really find the patterns too easily.
But yeah, maybe, you know, you probably do pretty well at finding patterns that are there just
because of some implementation bug or something like that. Yeah, you know, so people did apply
some kind of lattice methods to like, if you have bugs in your implementation, like for instance,
if you reuse nonce, then you, the number you're supposed to only use once, then it's actually
trivial to recover your private keys. And there are, in the sort of like a dark forest, you know,
tradition, there are bots who are looking for it. So if they, if they, if they ever find it,
your crypto is going to be instantly, instantly gone. Yeah. So there are people who are, who are
working on a lot of these sort of techniques, and they're already scanning the network for
possibility of this kind of stuff happening. Right. Yeah. Pretty amusing, in a way. It's kind of like
that. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Well, yeah, I think I'm gonna, gonna go take a break for a bit,
have a little bit of work I was gonna finish up. But yeah, I think this was, this was fun space,
this went well, we went through, you know, most of the material. So, and had a lot of interesting
questions and, and observations. So thank you. Your exposition is amazing. Thank you. Yeah.
Thank you, Max. Appreciate it. Thank you. Yeah, thanks everyone for coming. We, if everything goes
according to plan, we'll be having another one next week, same time. So yeah, please come out.
And yeah, thanks again, everyone. So see you guys. Bye bye.
you